the amount of blisters i've gotten from
mario party man
yeah my god whoever designed the
like yeah like he just hated humanity
he woke up and he chose violence
gamers welcome to this very special
episode of trash taste
i'm your host for today gamer and with
me is gamers
and gamers how are you doing gamers
it wasn't that funny god says gamer man
that was just the most forceful gamers
i was like oh [ __ ] as a gamer i was not
prepared for that's the game when you're
not prepared
so we all play video games yeah gamers
right so
i thought today that we could talk about
our tastes in gaming because i think we
spoke about what we like to play and all
that but we haven't actually sat down
and
reviewed each other's gaming properly or
at least tell each other our gaming
yeah so we've had like the anime episode
where we've probably
broken down our anime tastes even though
we've talked about anime before and
we're gonna be doing something similar
today so we have made
three three by threes for our games we
don't unfortunately we don't have a my
gaming list
which probably would have made it not a
thing i don't know that should be a
thing oh i'm sure there's like
i'm sure there's a thing of that but
it's just not i don't know it's just not
as prevalent in the gaming community i
feel
like i guess it's because it takes
longer to finish a game yeah
and it i'm going to be honest it made
this a lot harder
because i couldn't remember like most of
the games i played
literally it's just proven
like i'm not looking forward to this
episode because i'm probably going to
have the most boring gaming taste well
i've got godzilla's just going to be
like the top top selling games of all
time
that's that's it we sports nine times
tetris
we sport like for me like the
we were making our three by threes at
the same time these two finished within
10 minutes and i after about half an
hour i
made six and i'm just like are there
nine games i really care about i don't
know
i know i finished nine years nine games
that you care about
what are you gonna have a personal
retirement home like no
it's more than nine games no i i have
games that i played
that i enjoyed but like games that like
really meant something to me or games
like i think back and have like a
positive
right just like you just think yeah i
hated it
every game of time now i didn't enjoy
there were just so many games where i'm
just like yeah it was a game i played
you know like my father please stop
giving me shitty games
i don't want to play any shitty games i
enjoyed my time with it i don't know
i'm excited for this one because i feel
that you know with anime you guys are
like definitely the resident experts
right i feel like gaming
this is like this is yeah they're like
the reverse the the roles have been
reversed i mean look if there's anything
we know about the gaming communities
that they
love to [ __ ] on other people's opinions
right it's like
i i feel like regardless of what we put
on here there's going to be at least one
person being like
an amateur [ __ ] normies right here oh
definitely definitely i'm independence
you know i mean i'm fully prepared for
i'm fully
i fully realize i'm a normie when it
comes to games so i'm okay with that to
be nice
you think you're a normie i think i am
the most normie gamer
of your time considering the the list of
games that i've actually completed
is like i can probably count on my hand
wait why why do you not complete games
i don't i find it super super hard to
complete games
it needs to be like really good no
that's the thing that's the thing most
of the get like
because i tried to find the criteria of
like what i would put on my list right
and for anime it was
anime that i have at least re-watched
once for gaming i was just like
um if i complete that if i complete the
game then that's like a [ __ ]
s-tier game in my eyes because if if
it's if if i get to the end of the game
it must be a truly special imagine if
people did this for like movies they're
like
it's a good movie if i get to the end
yeah
because like for me for me like the most
most of most games i get to that 70
mark of completion right and at the 70
mark it's like you've you've discovered
most of the things the game can do for
you right and like you've unlocked most
of the abilities
like they literally don't end until they
end like like which games
on your list or just some of my games
talking about like like online games
well if you're doing story games you
know obviously you can't just quit 70
percent of the way and be like i've seen
the story i mean like
you'd be surprised that's not a story
that's that's a [ __ ] dictionary
you know unusual knowledge yeah and
that's why i think for me
um story's a massive thing because if it
doesn't have a good story
i ain't finishing the game no i agree
with that if i don't have good gameplay
i ain't even starting the game and i
i'm like i realize i'm such a [ __ ]
picky gamer
wait if there's if there is just one
aspect
of a game that just doesn't mesh with me
immediately then i just end up not
playing it
is anything that annoys me more than a
picky eater it's a picky game
your game especially especially now when
i just don't have time to play games if
i'm playing a game i play like
i think i play one or two games a year
right new games like it's hard not to
just go back to my comfort food and play
games i've
played before i have such a bad habit on
that where if there's
ever like a new game that just comes out
i think
it doesn't matter if i just started a
new game three days prior
let's be like i don't want to play with
you anymore and then i just play that
new like
so just three days ago as i was
recording this the monster hunter game
came out right
and i was like well i was gonna play
that anyway so it's fine but i was
really busy up until these last three
days so i only just picked it up
yesterday right but before that
like right before monster hunter came
out i had got the new super mario
game as well so i had played that new
super mario game for like literally four
days
and then i was like monster hunters out
alright ceo
i just immediately started a new game i
mean if it's like a really
you know a highly anticipated game that
you're waiting for yeah i get it oh no
but i'm like that with anything right
like if there's like a new game on like
steam that's like oh it's 20
off i guess i'll give it a go like i
feel like i'm one of those like if if
we're comparing it to like people who
eat food right yeah
i'm definitely one of those people who
just takes little bits off of the buffet
but doesn't actually finish what's on
their plate yeah before they go into it
whereas there are some people who are
like no
i'm getting one thing and i'm not gonna
move on to the next meal until i
finished it
okay so you know when it was like
christmas or your birthday
yeah you ever asked for more than one
video game did you ever do that no
you never asked more than one video no i
i did but it was like a hail mary i'm
just like
maybe maybe this is the year that all
happened maybe santa really loves me
this year and then if you get like
two or three games in one you know
birthday or christmas it's like yeah
how do you whoa whoa yeah where who do i
begin with how do i split this time
evenly like that sounds like
i think my seven-year-old life peaked
when i got an entire game console for
christmas i got an n64
and that was like man my career's peaked
i am
life is never gonna peak after this what
am i what am i even living for man yeah
i was i was like that when i got the
game boy advance when i was like five i
was like
there's so much power in my hands every
other every other thing i've ever done
out the window because like one of the
big problems i had when making my 3x3
was that
i there were games that i knew i loved
as a kid but then i don't remember [ __ ]
about them
well there's there's some there's
somewhere if you ask me to play them now
i'm sure i could be like i don't
remember exactly what happened all i
know is that i put way too many hours
and yes like
so uh yeah i mean should we just get
into that then we can talk about other
gaming stuff after
yeah sure sure should we get trashcan i
think our names are still on the boat
all right
are they all great let's figure it out
okay they are
let's find out who's going to be roasted
and the first one is oh it's gone it's
gone oh it's me
okay i guess we're moving okay start
starting things off easy i see i can't
wait this is going to be fun
is there anything you boys expect on
this gaming list i have a film that
league is going to be on there
i have a few yeah uh as far as anything
else goes
league i expect to be on there right um
i don't know what other games you've
played you never talk about video games
i don't talk about video games often do
i you're like you're like hentai
anime hentai anime video games what
video games do i
i swear to god if fate is on here i'm
gonna be sure i'm gonna be so
angry if fake grand order is on
yeah i i didn't put fate on here because
i mean i i play i
don't think about putting i did put i
don't know i did think
about putting not fate but uh genjin
impact on there
okay yeah i was really really [ __ ]
into it
in your life okay well then you want to
go through the nine games you have all
right so
starting at the top mass effect 3 tales
of symphonia
persona 5 zelda wind waker liga legends
super mario sunshine metal gear solid 3
subnautica gears of war 2. i look at
this and i'm just like
this is the most random [ __ ]
game not expecting like half of the
games you put on here i honestly i
expected myself to put more anime games
on and i'm just realizing
what i haven't really finished any games
i mean the only real anime games on here
is probably
symphonia and persona right yeah and
those are the only like i'm thinking
what other anime type game series are
there
uh that are famous because when i think
of anime video games i'm just like tail
series persona series yeah
uh those are the only anime video games
yeah i got like 20 something hours in
and i was like wow
20 hours into a jlpg yeah that's
impressive i was like this is
so boring literally like
all the fights of the [ __ ] stuff yeah
welcome to jrpg
yeah like i'm completely okay so here's
the thing for the longest time
i've really really tried to get into
jrpgs like as a kid the reason the
reason tales is on here
is that as a kid i like i knew i would
love jrpgs and like the
aesthetic and the story and everything
because i love anime yeah the problem is
i hated turn-based battles like
i i couldn't [ __ ] stand turn-based
battles and that would like put me off
getting more than
say five hours into any jrpg because i
would just get turned off by the
turn-based battles
and so i was like as a kid i was waiting
for a game that was an anime game
that just did not have a turn-based
battle system and also random encounters
i
[ __ ] hate random encounters as well
okay right
wait wait okay you say that though but
persona 5 is literally that i know okay
persona 5
it doesn't have random encounters but
persona 5 is literally the game
that broke jrpgs for me because i mean
even as someone who hasn't played it or
plays jrpgs it's still that grpg that i
look at and i'm like
i know that's a good game like i don't
need to play it to know that's a good
thing yeah yeah you just look at it
i won't play it but yeah yeah like i can
see everything about it that this is a
banger of a game
i'm not gonna play it because i don't
own a console that can play it and
honestly do i want to get into that [ __ ]
no but it's like a [ __ ] good game
like
with persona 5 um i don't know it was
it's the only turn-based battle game
where i just didn't get bored of the
battle system and i don't know why it's
something i think it's
it's the theme man it's it's it's it's a
bit of everything right because it just
it's really good at tricking your mind
into thinking that this isn't turn-based
battle
that's that's the best way i can
describe which is like the sexiest
animations alive
yeah yeah yeah it's just got like so
many colors the music [ __ ] slaps
um you can like you get different
abilities as you go on and i don't know
like it's it's something it's it's
really good at tricking your mind into
thinking man this is this just
it just feels almost like a rhythm game
a point right right you know it's it
it's i i can't put my words on why
that battle system out of everything
just
trumped any other jrpg battle system um
because i can't
i can't think of any other jrpg i enjoy
even though i even i
i say i'm a jrpg enjoyer right
i have the most basics so then why did
you put tales of symphonia there
specifically
tales of symphonia okay so because for
me if i would have put a tails gate
because i've played
most of the tales games i played one
tales game i don't know what the [ __ ]
was happening so if you want to explain
to me what it's about because i
legitimately don't know anything i'm
sure the viewers who haven't played it
because if i were to put a tales game on
there personally i would have put
zysteria on there
yeah which one's exterior again series
the one after symphonia
okay i would have put uh the only one i
can think of is vesperia
yeah which is which is like i'm just i'm
just throwing out words for connor here
they all sound so similar already
mysterious
yeah i mean it's like final fantasy one
two three four i can follow
yeah i mean i mean the best way i can
describe it it's just basically uh
it's just basically anime as anime the
video game like it's
it's it's really that simple jrpgs are
just to me
i i know i can get into most grpgs if i
like the combat and battle system
because it's just anime the video game
right and i like anime i'm a [ __ ]
weeb
therefore equation equals you like the
tail series yeah yeah right
and um the reason tells of symphonia one
there was it was my
first experience with just realizing
that
whoa you can play a video game and it
feels like you're watching an anime
well this is this is amazing what's up
like i can't i can't believe i've just
discovered this in my life and i was so
obsessed with this right because it's um
these are two of the only jrpgs i've
ever finished but i was so obsessed with
it
that i got to the 80 point as i do with
most video games and then i just
stopped playing it and i didn't stop
playing it because i got bored
i stopped playing it because i didn't
want that experience to end
i didn't i didn't want to see the end
credits and know that that experience
is over yeah so like i stopped playing
it for about
i i held on to that for about two
[ __ ] years
of my life just just just so just so i
know
that i have i have the ending of tales
of symphonia
to look forward to in my life like that
that was that was like the peak of life
right right
off after this you must go to hold a nut
you literally blue ball
that's that monk controller kicking in
yeah
the funny thing is so i'm just like
after after about two years i'm like
okay i think it's time to complete tales
of some phonemes
start playing it's time to not yeah i
think it's time to finally not start
playing
start playing it again and then i
realize [ __ ] i don't know
anything i can't remember anything
that's going on yeah so what did i do
i just replayed it from the beginning
and i was like 80 hours in already
um so i put like a good 150 160 hours
into this game yeah
um persona 5 i actually haven't replayed
okay because it's quite long it's quite
a long time it's quite a long game and
compared to tales when i was a kid i had
plenty of time to [ __ ] replay games
back then because i assume persona is
probably on your list as well
because you yeah oh i've played persona
5
four times you've played it more than me
yeah but
i remember the reason persona's on there
is that out of like a lot of games in my
adult life
it like for the first time in a long
time you know
it felt like i was a kid again and i was
just like
uh how how can i how can i put this into
words when i experienced persona 5 i
didn't know
that i could feel this way just just
like
being really excited about just being
really excited about a game and just
discovering in
this new world and uh god i i killed my
feelings when i was an adult
and the person five reminded me it
really did it
i don't know it was i was just like yo
this is anime and it's a video game i'm
enjoying it again it's it's like it's
like discovering anime for the first
time again
right right and yeah like i i i always i
always
everyone always told me you know you're
like the soda series you're like sony
series and i'm just like not a [ __ ]
word it's got turn-based battles in
there why the [ __ ] would i like that
it's got turn-based battles and then
they are like the worst system of any
combat system in any game
like it's like far and beyond one of the
few things i can agree on donkey with
right you know and that's that's like
the big reason why i haven't you know i
i couldn't get into a lot of the final
fantasies never played final fantasy 7.
um i'll probably start playing final
fantasy 7 remake because that doesn't
have turn-based battles
i mean i was telling myself i was going
to play final fantasy 7 for like the
past 10 years
because it's one of those games like i'm
going to play it yeah of course i'm
going to play it
well i mean yeah the time passed yeah
but i mean i remember i did boot up
final fantasy 7 and the first time i'm
on steam and i was like oh the place is
the original one yeah i'm like yeah oh
it's hideous yeah it looks like
absolute [ __ ] i can't do this like cloud
with like the egg beat of hands
yeah yeah it looks [ __ ] horrible now
yeah because i
you talked about you know when a new
hype game comes out then you just drop
whatever you're playing
and just start playing that i have like
the opposite problem i have
i i don't know what i don't know if
there's an actual term for it i think i
i think i'm gonna i'm just gonna coin a
term now yeah i get hype fatigue
right so so like there are times when i
see the
i see a new game like announced at e3 or
something yeah i see all
i i see all like the you know the
gameplay and like
the developers showing off gameplay
footage and trailers and i'm like i like
follow through
that i'm like super super hyped for this
game because i think i'm really really
gonna like this game
and i get so hype that i kind of hype
myself
out of it once the game actually comes
out like i used all your hype
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's so
weird like i was like that with the
final fantasy 7 remake
because i'm like dude i can finally
enjoy final fantasy 7
because it's removed the shitty part
that i hate about final fantasy the
turn-based combat and the random
encounters
so in theory i should love this game
because this is one of the greatest
jrpgs of all time everyone always talks
about it
i was hyped for it to come out i was
hyped for it for years
and then it came out and then i just was
just like maybe i'll play it
that's a really good point i think that
league of legends killed my ability
to get hyped for games yeah because i
knew that at the end of the day most of
the time i would just return to league
of legends
yeah yeah so it didn't matter what game
came out anyway because i would play it
for a week and i'd be like
all right back to league yeah it's like
and so now
even though i don't really play league
anymore even when a game that i probably
am excited for
like is announced or whatever i'm just
like while someone's on twitter going
through you know like the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'm just like
i mean yeah it's like you know when it
comes it's kind of like that you know
whole thing of like oh like a new
restaurant just opened up that
everyone's [ __ ] knives about i'll go
check it out but then you go have a meal
there it might be the best [ __ ] meal
of your life but then you know you'll be
like
all right i'm going to mcdonald's
tomorrow it's just it's just comfort
food right or comfort game yeah it's
just like there's always that like
fallback of
yeah you know this is a cool game and
all yeah like i'm sure i'll love it if i
just kept going on with it yeah
but at the same time it's like i'll i'll
just replay this thing
i wonder as well if you're into story
games more which i think the people who
are chasing like the hype are more into
story games because when you're a
multiplayer gamer
yeah mainly like me it's like well i'm
just gonna keep playing the same [ __ ]
game
so like why would i get hyped over
anything when if there's a new game i'll
probably end up switching to it if it's
a new multiplayer game yeah yeah
so it's kind of hard for me to get
hacked about because it's like a
catch-22 for me right because i i really
value good stories
in video games but also like especially
now as an adult i think i just have
commitment issues with games
like unless i know that i'm going to be
committed to this game for the next week
of my life which
finding heart finding time to commit to
a game for the next week of my life
is like a big [ __ ] commitment now it
is it is so hard
that sometimes i just go back to my
comfort food of just like maybe
replaying massive
like when when cyberpunk got released i
was super super hyped about cyberpunk
and then it got released and then i'm
just like i don't really feel like
playing cyberphone i
and i just started playing mass effect
again
because like you might choose your dick
size in mass effect
because i know the story of mass effect
i know i'm going to enjoy the story of
mass effect and
i know but i i think over like
pre-overexposure in terms of like gaming
is
is a big thing for me because a lot of
people hype up games to know to no end
and
i don't think that people i don't think
in anime at least this is as big of a
problem
or as big of like a thing where people
do you know people get hyped about
anime as it's airing people rarely get
hyped about anime or super super hyped
about anime before it starts airing but
with video games
you have years and years to like pump
yourself up
for this game cyberpunk hyping up right
it was ridiculous
i am surprised though that i wasn't
expecting
i thought i was gonna be the only
nintendo simp on this
at this table so i'm glad that you have
at least like a couple of nintendo games
here okay okay okay
so let me ask you this was wind wake
your first zelda
it was the first zelda that i finished
that's normally how it goes yeah that's
usually
cause my favorite was like twilight
princess and i know that it's not the
best one because i think breath of the
wild is better than twilight princess
yeah but twilight prince is still
[ __ ]
so yeah but i saw a game but it's only
because i like i think that was the
first one that i finished
like when you finish a zelda game
there's something about it that feels
like so
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're a kid yeah i
mean i i it was like really hard for me
to pick between
wind waker and uh breath of the wild i
was [ __ ] obsessed with breath of the
wild when i when it came out because i
remember
when i started getting into breath of
the wild um was
the first time that i came to japan with
sydney the first time
the first time i met you um and i
remember
like i had a great time in japan first
time in japan of course you can have a
great [ __ ] time but i remember no
matter how many times
no matter how many times i went to
archibald no matter how many times we
hung out and everything
at the back of my mind i was just like i
kind of just want to go
i could be playing breath of the wild
right now
like i'm just like you know [ __ ] joey
man like oh come on come on joey
you're good but are you breath of the
wild dude i don't know about that
you could have said that to my face i
would have been like you know what i
ain't mad i kind of agree
i don't have to agree with you there to
be fair though i wasn't expecting
sunshine for some reason
okay out of all you don't seem like a
sunshine player why don't i seem like a
sunshine no i don't know you just don't
you two don't seem like nintendo game i
know i know you're not but
you definitely don't seem like that
because i think
uh the only re the the only nintendo
games out on here are like my childhood
nintendo games
yeah yeah because i was definitely a
nintendo kid i i was such nintendo simp
when i was a kid
yeah i i was like i i didn't i never
owned
any other console apart from the nes
super nest
n64 gamecube and it was only after
gamecube that i finally ventured out
which i
which is why i just didn't own a wii
right and i think since then the switch
is the first nintendo console i actually
owned right and so
i still i still like out of all the
nintendo games
these two pop outs me as the ones that i
think they're
like the most popular honestly
it's like most popular 3d mario and most
popular 3d zelda
i mean i think wind waker is great i
think
ah you could you could pick wind waker
or breath the wild as number one and i
i'd be i you know i can't hate on both
right because i mean at the end of the
day but like
like a lot of people who grew up my age
they put ocarina of time and
i you know i i'm not gonna lie i don't
understand the hype
no i played okay okay i thought no i i
kind of got bored of ocarina of time
like i kind of did it
it's like how like i think wind waker
again it's like the art style right when
wicket aged [ __ ]
fantastically mm-hmm ocarina did not age
well
like you played that [ __ ] now it is like
[ __ ] impossible to play
like i've always said like ocarina of
time for the zelda franchise is a lot
like final fantasy 7 for the final
fantasy franchise where it's like
because it was the first 3d game yeah
after a long succession of 2d games
obviously when the 3d like [ __ ] was
starting right it was impressive right
so people immediately were like it's in
3d yeah
automatically 10 out of 10. i also
didn't grow up with it so
you know i i ended up playing it later
oh yeah
even like now right to me when i you
know who i've played all the games
from wind waker onwards i just think
like when i'm looking at
ocarina of time like you know majora's
mess looks so much more interesting oh
yeah in like every single way this game
looks [ __ ]
weird i agree yeah it's so cool but like
have you ever played majora's mask
i did like about two hours and then i
was like [ __ ] this is so hard
mcdonald's lasts as hard as [ __ ] it's
really hard no i would 100 prefer
playing majora's mask over ocarina of
time just because like
again like it's well i mean for for one
both are hard as [ __ ]
yeah it's not like playing it on the
emulator i don't know why someone feels
wrong about playing nintendo 64. yeah
because i have majora's mask
on like because i have like a proper
ncaa yeah i know you and i have majora's
mask
yeah and it's like i don't know the
feeling is kind of the same to me
yeah i don't know maybe it's like yeah i
want to go back and play them
yeah yeah but again like i don't
understand people who are like ocarina
of time is the greatest zelda game i'm
like i'm sorry
it's not it's not it hasn't i'm going to
get a whole lot
about this but it's the look i've i've
publicly said
that yeah i'm sorry but final fantasy
vii is not the best
again it's what combo bebop is to
animate right it's like it's the one
that's what it is that's what it is it's
like it's the one you probably watched
first it's the one that probably got
you into the franchise or yeah to the
medium right yeah but that doesn't mean
it's the best yeah
i mean i agree because these might be
the ones from my childhood that
you know i have the fondest memories of
but they weren't the first zelda or
mario that i played in my life
i'm surprised you didn't have uh super
mario 64 on there because
you're such a boomer these aren't boomer
pics
where are your boomer pigs these are way
too neat because the thing is i'm not
i'm not like a
super massive mario fan i i did you know
i have i have completed
64 completed sunshine completed what's
the most recent mario game
honestly honestly i mean i completed
them not got all the shiny
shines or you know but i got to the end
game beat bowser the final time
yeah um so you know i have completed
them but
out of all the marios that i've played
i just think there's something about
sunshine you know you know when you
think back to a game and it just it just
vibes with you like like look the
feeling just vibes yeah
that's sunshine i feel like sunshine is
just clean okay
it's literally in the name sunshine okay
if you couldn't tell i'm a bit of a
summer kid right
i mean we've had many arguments about
this where like i
[ __ ] does that does that mean
anything though it does just because i
like the winter i'm not gonna go get
[ __ ]
mario at the [ __ ] winter olympics all
right he's playing he's playing [ __ ]
mario 64 gets to the snow level turns it
off
no no that is exactly what happens
you guys call me
you know you know there are some levels
out there where you you hit you hit her
and you're just like
oh it's this level again like every
[ __ ] water level in any [ __ ] video
game of all time but i'm not like oh
[ __ ] you know what's one thing i
hate about the stage the weather i've
never been like literally like that
like what's wrong with you no like when
i played mario sunshine
and like i i loved it because every
level is like
every level gives off that summer
feeling and that summer vibe
which i [ __ ] love yeah and it's like
the the ones i hated the levels that i
hated the most
in mario sunshine were like the boo
levels something where it's like dark
and
scary level [ __ ] yeah the pachinko
level is the [ __ ] one
yeah yeah but like for the most part
it's it gives off a very summery vibe
and
i think back to that i'm just like yeah
i [ __ ] with this i'm
it just makes me happy it gives me the
good feeling oh i get that i get that
they're like it's like so hard to it's
gonna be such a boring part of their
podcast where we're just like damn gone
you have
good i mean like this is categorically
just two great games
yeah i mean like exactly congratulations
guys you have good taste
oh my god oh god i've become connor now
you're mean this is super vanilla
uh i mean i'll i'm not i'll happily say
that this is super vanilla um
i mean it's also just interesting
because it's like i think it's because
we just
never [ __ ] talk about the games that
we're into so like i never expected like
subnautica
like gears war to be there yeah what the
[ __ ] why okay i love [ __ ] gears of
war
why is it on your list okay so i
i had a hard choice putting my not yeah
my last three
um so gears of war is on there because
it is the first multiplayer game that's
it was the game
that is on there because that's how i
discovered online gaming
and i'm just like matt gears of war was
a good [ __ ] online game no dude it
was clean
yeah and honestly gears of war 2 was
really the first game where i was like
whoa video games can like make me sad
wait what oh the story is okay no i
didn't give a [ __ ] about the story the
story's so
good i don't even think i finished that
why am i what are we swapping
bro this story is so good i literally
put this on here because
like i had such a hard time because i'm
just like i didn't give a [ __ ] about the
story i didn't understand there's one
thing i remember about geez award too
it's the story the story is so
i remember this again it doesn't count
as spoilers anymore it's so [ __ ] old
yeah what's the story again um the
locusts are taking over the earth and
they're basically stopping them etc etc
i mean that's basically like the wow no
no
because there was like the there were
the two duo who you're following which
is uh
i just remember one guy trying to look
for his wife or something that was the
sad part
and then he like finds it but then he
didn't find it it was like an illusion
and then i'm like what the [ __ ]
i was like i was like 13. i was like i'm
like what this is
this [ __ ] massive lead hit of a
character just like breaks down in the
battlefield i'm just like oh my god
i was just like this is the first game
when i'm just like oh chainsaw
that's how it gets you in right so giza
will get you in with the chainsaw go
bruh
super manly men and then 10 minutes in
you're [ __ ] crying and you're like
whoa what's happening
no no for me the one memory i hold for
gears of war two the multiplayer
is just the sound you the sound it makes
when you pop a guy's head off with a
sniper like
yeah i played two yeah like that was i
think that soul
sound and i don't know why it was so
[ __ ] satisfying because it was
it was like literally cracking an egg
well i mean those those those shotguns
are like still there's like no
multiplayer experience like the online
and gears of war
it's just shotguns yeah yeah yeah like
that's like the meta it's like you have
to run up to people and shotgun each
other yeah right
okay the shotgun was also really
satisfying when you got like a point
blank and
the body just explodes yeah my god like
i
like you're the monkey brain but that
was like the first time i'm just like
okay i i i enjoy this now this is fun uh
it was really sex i think uh gears of
war got plagued by the fact that there
was just like a
like uh there would always be like uh
two really [ __ ] god tier
players in the game that could just
dominate the whole lobby yeah so it just
kind of became
not fun after a while if you weren't
like a pro yeah you just get [ __ ]
destroyed by the like good players i def
i didn't play on i didn't play online
gears of war two a lot because
i didn't know what console was it on
again 360. three years because i didn't
own a 360 because yeah i played at my
friend's place a lot just like land
multiplayer and that was like really
really fun but yeah
yeah i probably from the sounds of it i
probably wouldn't enjoy it online
no you probably wouldn't now i mean it
was me discovering
what multiplayer meant and before i
started hating okay
gears of war started my love for
multiplayer games league of legends
killed it
okay league of legends
is in the middle because i think out of
out out of all these games
i have probably played league of legends
the most right not proud to admit it
um but the reason it's on there is
because i think
the honeymoon period of league of
legends for me was probably
the best gaming experience of my life
it's
really long for me as well i'm just like
like two years long that's a long
honeymoon
dude when you get into that game and
it's going well it feels so fun yeah
that's great it's so fun to get into
it's just it's hard yeah because the
problem is now i feel like
multiplayer games just aren't fun unless
you are getting into it
immediately as it's released right
because the problem the problem with
multiplayer games i found now
is that you have a new game and that's
when a new game just gets released
that's the fun part because nobody
nobody really knows how to be good at
the game
everyone's just kind of like really
discovering what
works and what doesn't everyone's just
[ __ ] having fun yeah and then you get
to a point in multiplayer
where people just realize how to
optimize the fun out of the game the
sweaty boys
that's what happened with like fortnight
honestly like honestly like
me all memes aside fortnight was so fun
when it first came out yeah
it blew up and then when i got to the
point where everyone would like build a
[ __ ] mortgage right in front of your
eyes within 10 seconds and you couldn't
do anything it's like well this is just
not fun anymore
i don't have the dexterity of like a
chimp on cr on like coke right like
how am i supposed to do this yeah
because i remember like i really really
[ __ ] enjoyed overwatch when it first
came out yeah me too like i i i never
wrote i i didn't make the same mistake
of trying to do ranked um
because because i'd learned from league
of legends but even just playing
casually i really really [ __ ] enjoyed
it
and then they got to a point when even
in casual games
you weren't allowed to have fun anymore
you got this the same the same
uh the same heroes exchange of hanzo
i mean i i i would fully admit i was
like a genji main because i was a dirty
leaf
and the reason i played genji was
because i [ __ ] sucked at genji
but like the one the one time out of ten
where i i didn't alt and it actually
worked out that was the reason
i played genji like nine out of ten
times i would completely flunk it i
would fail i would get killed straight
away
but that one time that one time when it
worked out i that
that that's what i lived for man and
because of that i was one of the most
talked
i wasn't the most toxic ones but i was i
was that one genji on your team
that probably threw you the magic i was
that i was that person did you talk [ __ ]
to your teammates
i didn't talk i'm not a toxic gamer
funnily enough i'm just like
oh come on guys we can do it if we are
all put together
we can win with the power of friendship
come on guys oh my god
and ranked you had to get to start like
shouting at people get them to shut up
i'm just like i'm just like that guy who
just goes mutual and just does my own
thing
yeah i do that sometimes too i mean i i
play it as closely as
a single-player game as i can because um
like playing online game just makes me
makes you realize how [ __ ] how much i
hate people
people are the worst especially in
competitive ones right that's why like
but in japan it's so weird because like
people just don't smack talk
at all they don't know how to yeah they
should like
and most you'll get passive aggression
yeah like i'd probably i'd probably
enjoy japanese comparison
no one talks unless you talk to them
because i play in the league servers in
japan
and like ninety percent of them are just
chinese smurfs yeah so of course they're
like toxic as [ __ ] you know
yeah so i don't really play anymore
because it's just like you can't [ __ ]
have fun in league of legends
it's just like a korean chinese
playground but they're like oh let's go
and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] with the japanese players who
are suck at this game yeah it's it's
literally just
it's literally it's just the playground
where the school bullies go to to just
like bully like this
they're just like lebron james coming
down to the elementary match
to start dunking you know you feel like
you suck
metal gear whatever i mean that's good
you can't what can i say
yeah no one can complain about that i
mean you could put any metal gear in
there it would have been good
i mean for me like do you know do you
know the reason i enjoyed metal gear
why because i i've played all metal
gears it's in
except for metal gear five really
apparently the best one in terms of
gameplay
it is the best one i have really no
kind of once to play it exclusive the
hype fatigue
no no no no okay i get it you feel like
you had your film no i i didn't have my
feel like i was hype as [ __ ] for it and
then what is it
and then i found out that the story was
kind of like incomplete and i'm just
like okay
well that that that just takes the
reason absolutely middle gear absolutely
more incomplete by not playing it yeah
yeah yeah that doesn't make any sense
it's it's not finished and i haven't
finished it so i'm not gonna do any more
it doesn't deserve my time okay like how
how do you feel about this connor
like when you play have you ever played
metal gear uh
no okay none of them uh no because i it
was like
i don't know why but like i never really
saw it in like the shops
probably because it was also on
playstation as well right i had
playstation 2 growing up
right but yeah for some reason i was
probably playing like shrek and spyro
and damn [ __ ] like that
good choice i was really like yeah when
i was uh when i was younger i wasn't
attracted at all to like the
fps art or like the like military
looking stuff
right i always went for the childish
cartoonish
yeah yeah even when i was like 14 15 i
would still like to prefer the cartoon
anime style over
yeah so i i normally avoided those so i
was playing like [ __ ] theme park
games and [ __ ] when i was like 15. like
rollercoaster tycooning
well playstation had its like uh its own
brand of like these theme park games
yeah and i think they're still quite
popular on youtube occasionally
and you could like you could build the
rides and ride them from
like pov first person oh wow it was
really cool [ __ ]
do you know what i'm on about no no i i
i'm just getting a flashback of memories
now
maybe i should have put that on there
because i've spent far too much time on
theme park or
yeah theme park and theme hospital yeah
yeah i i think you know roller coaster
tycoon is
like [ __ ]
yeah i'm just like [ __ ] man maybe i
should have put that on my list but uh
yeah in terms of like i never got got
into the roller coaster tycoon because
uh theme park had like the voiced person
telling you what to do
and i don't know something about having
someone voiced telling you what to do
was was a big selling point for me was
that the one the playstation 2 that i'm
on about
maybe i don't know i don't know i don't
know when we have a break
yeah but it definitely had a pov option
where you could build the rides and then
yeah because you could ride it yeah you
could and there's like racing games in
it so when you built like the racing
track you built the track yourself and
then you could race around it oh that
sounds cool
yeah dude it was awesome why am i never
heard of this and then like
you could [ __ ] i want to play it now
there was like
there was like the the normal park there
was like an alien park
yeah you remember this and each each
world had like
different ride things that you could
ride and like you you couldn't progress
to the next world unless your theme park
was x successful
that just sounds like rollercoaster
tycoon it is like tycoon but like better
because like rollercoaster tycoon is
pure like top down yeah it's just like
you get in there you can walk around
your path
yeah this is the box art i'm going to
find it
i know what the box art looks like i
think they released other types of games
as well but this is the one that like i
literally
played to death in the ps2 no i you you
are you are reminding me now and i'm
just like [ __ ] i didn't play on ps2 i
played it on pc
it was on pc as well yeah yeah yeah i
was on pc um [ __ ] man
nostalgia no because i i [ __ ] loved
simulator games like that i can i could
never get to the sims but i [ __ ] love
like
sim city theme hospital um
rollercoaster tycoon not very close to
tycoon uh theme park as you said yeah
god i put so much just hit him with that
nostalgia oh this is yeah
so that's why i like i never really
played military games because i would
always see like the like the bright
light boxes and i think i'm like you
know being a [ __ ] 14 15 year old
you're like
no i was exactly the same when like uh
when like heavy rain came
out yeah and i looked at the box and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is that yeah
and now i regret not playing it back in
the day because much many years later
i was like this game's [ __ ] fantastic
because like i loved like crash
bandicoot
so much on the ps2 yeah and like that
was the kind of art style that i
normally gravitated towards so wow
right right like there's so many games
you've like yeah even all the spin-offs
are crash bandicoot yeah like crash
racing
uh they had like the mario party s kind
of game called like crash bash which i
really liked as well i've heard of that
even though it's a terrible game right
now but i used to play it a bunch and
then
crash one two and you know
the only racing game that could legit
compete against mario kart
no no no no no uh what was the uh
did he congratulations diddy kong racing
is up there
come on really it is up
the n64 version because that was when it
could actually compete with
well it was made by rare right yeah you
know i could see
i remember like 10 year old me going to
my friend's place and he had diddy kong
racing on near n64 and i'm like
wait you can ride on aeroplanes yeah and
like boats what the [ __ ]
yeah like for me i was really close
putting banjo-kazooie on here
oh my god
it's good it's good what can i say and
uh yeah i don't know like
okay so part like a big reason why that
i had so few games to pick up
to pick from right is because when i
really get into game
i really get into a game i i
wring out as much content as i can out
of that game
every side quest every little piece of
dialogue i play it to death so i can get
everything like with let's say so with
metal gear
right so there would be times where you
know
are you familiar with the codec calls
they would like call you up and be like
yeah snake
yeah yeah exactly so so one one of the
big criticisms of metal gear when you
know i was playing it and you know when
it was like really really big was
people hated the cut scenes how long the
cut scenes were people hated
the fact that you had to go through all
these codec calls
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] man i'm like
i'm like holy [ __ ] there's an hour cut
scene be right back getting the popcorn
i
this is the most epic gameplay i could
ever hope for was metal gears
three the one with like psycho mantis is
that the one it was that was the first
one that was a photo
yeah the first one was like the top down
like
nes one i don't know i mean that's metal
gear that's metal gear not metal gear
solid
solid yeah yeah yeah because like every
time i watch because i've watched tons
of
videos about metal gear and every time i
watch it i'm like [ __ ] i wish i got this
when i was a kid because
it looks badass it was [ __ ] badass
and but the thing the thing is like okay
so there's metal gear and there's tails
as well tails has
this feature right i mean you play the
tails game yeah how did you think about
the skits feature
or skits what was that
okay oh wait is this what you talk with
the character and like the fire emblem
thing
what wait what where you interact with
characters no am i crazy
kind of so in intel's games they have
this thing called
skits right where you'll be walking
around and then you press like the
select button when they give you a
prompt right
and it would just be characters talking
to each other
oh yeah i'd never i'd always see this i
didn't do it
so like i was probably the one [ __ ]
person
who just hit every skit button like i i
don't care what
what time i'm in what like at which
point of the story
i would just like i literally played
tails and i literally like
there are some skits that are only that
that only happen
at certain areas of the map which are
like some areas of the map you literally
have to walk
on the other side of the map and there
was no like quick well this is a big
boulder huh
yeah it sure is it literally doesn't
mean [ __ ] yeah and it literally doesn't
mean [ __ ]
i [ __ ] love that feature i don't know
man i
like because here's the if i love the
characters and i love the world i'm
i'm getting every kind of like i'm
getting kind of interacting with
same thing with mass effect when people
talk about how much they love mass
effect
they talk about oh you know the
character writing and
you know the well not so much the
gameplay anymore but like the world
and the characters that uh of mass
effect
um i was probably i like i remember
there's there was one mass effect
game play session i had where i
literally wasted an hour or two
because in mass effects they have this
it's not a codec function but like a
database function where
they literally have a database of like
every
like the history and law of like every
alien every world
that you go to so i literally i
literally spent
an hour or two of mass effect going
through the entire database
and just and just reading the whole law
of mass effect i'd rather not i'd rather
not you know
and i [ __ ] loved it i i absolutely
loved it um i can't even shake my head
because i used to do that
exact same thing without you guys
because i want to play a game read a
book or some [ __ ]
the [ __ ] i did i did that recently
actually when i played xenoblade 2 for
the first time
and there's this like there's this part
where like every monster you encounter
has like a full page about like
how it lives and [ __ ] yeah i read
through all of them i'm like oh okay
so like the zafaros only lives in the
swamps
like to to me that's that's what really
makes a video game
like it's especially because if if i'm
like really into a video game
i'm going to find out everything i can
about that video game and that's what
like but the thing there's a difference
right because i like
when it's just fed to me in video games
like people
have talked about you know the law of
dark souls and everything like that
and people have like figured stuff out
through the subtle hints that you get
through playing the game
i'm just like just tell me it just just
yeah just just give me exposition this
is the one time where i actually want
exposition
you say that all i think about is the
[ __ ] um the silent hill person
who's like um no no sorry so there's
like on on silent hill forums
there's like where they discuss like
what the game's about and stuff yeah it
was like a really big
thing and a big like like controversial
like drama because
one of like the main admins who had like
some of the most posts on it was like
convinced
that the main character was circumcised
and that was the reason for his like
trauma
and that he was like gay or something
yeah and then he was gay because of it
or something like that
and so there's this whole like dude like
wang made like a 20 minute video about
it
and it's like this whole thing where it
was like a massive deal on the forum so
they're discussing
you know is and then the guy was like
you know he was on like a crusade being
like no one should be circumcised it
causes trauma and stuff like that
and it turns like a whole thing and i'm
just like this is what people do
in my mind i'm like that's people who
read story that's what they do
they go on forums talk about why the
main character is gay and his
circumcision was trauma
yeah yeah what's wrong with these people
play a [ __ ] video game why why are
you typing about it
i'm not even surprised by that
yeah i i that's so like when you when
i'm relieved and you like it being
like the story being told to you yeah
you're like i want to figure it out is
my character actually like gay or
something
let me see circumstance i need to yeah i
need to figure it out
hideo
which is funny like i'm more than happy
to watch anime where i'm just like oh
what's the subtle
what's the subject what is the author
trying to say but with gaming i'm just
like nah no patience
just just give me well because you're
already focused on like actually playing
the game yeah yeah yeah yeah whereas
like no no i don't need to like i don't
want to like sit here and [ __ ]
guess what the story is what i'm trying
to do this convoluted input right yeah
and there's there's also another thing
that uh also
like it it's gonna be it's gonna sound
super weird but sometimes
i hate choice in video games i just want
a linear game which is which is funny
that massive yeah
literally the [ __ ] mass effect
literally mass effect persona five but
like
yeah yeah mass effect and persona five
which are the two like let's say
the two uh most choice heavy games yeah
two of the most choice every games and
the two
exceptions the two exceptions to that
rule but i have i have this thing i
i don't know if i'm the only person who
has like gaming fomo where i'm given a
choice
and and i know that like by by making
this choice i'm going to miss out on a
certain
piece of content oh yeah yeah i hate
that
i hate that so much right because that
means that means
in the back of my mind i'm just like but
what if i pick the other choice
and and well that's literally the reason
why i replayed persona 5 four times
because i was like well there's four
choices
yeah and i want to see all of them so
i'm gonna play it four times to get all
the choices
i i think it's unfortunate that i i like
swore off jrpgs after playing blue
dragon
not really which i mean i think i've
mentioned this before yeah
yeah the one that was like i think the
main selling point that comments were
saying is that it was uh the art was
made by the dragon ball uh guy oh yeah
toriyama here yeah and like
i never encountered this before in a
video game and this is what really
pissed me off
because at this point i was an
achievement hunter guy so i would always
go in like 100
i would get all all the achievements no
matter what yeah this is the first time
i encountered the thing where i'm like
okay so this story's two hours long or
some dumb [ __ ] like that it's
ridiculously long
yeah and i did it and then i'm like all
right how do i get these last few
achievements and it'd be like
this achievement is on the forum would
say this like this achievement is only
unlockable by doing this one option in
this one mission yeah yeah
you can never get this achievement yeah
yeah like what
what say suck
that that's such a jrpg movie and that's
so [ __ ] up
that they would do that like what kind
of sick [ __ ] does that
they're like i don't want anyone to be
able to get this achievement make them
play the whole [ __ ] like 200 hour
game again
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's no need to do
that why would you do that as a game
designer
i don't know forget you it's to get you
to replay the game right
yeah i mean i.e [ __ ] [ __ ]
everything i mean
like the the reason i hate it is because
it takes it takes enough energy for me
to finish a game once
so i'm thinking [ __ ] if i need to replay
this game i'm just not going to see this
contest
right yeah yeah dude if you want to see
the shitty turn based combat you should
play blue dragon man
[ __ ] every time you [ __ ] start a
battle the [ __ ] the mute the main
song starts playing yeah it's a guy
[ __ ] singing it sounds like the
pokemon intro
and then it takes like 20 seconds of
animations where they all like
summon their things which is like it's
like 20 seconds long before you can even
start the [ __ ] turn
don't tempt me don't tempt me like that
dude i'm excited oh it's [ __ ] garbage
and it's toriyama dude that
is like right up my alley garbage i also
hate in jrpgs that like
they give you these characters and like
what if you hate the characters that you
have to use
like in pokemon at least i can swap out
you know bulbasaur but like most jrpgs
like it's you know like especially with
the turn-based ones right it's like you
can only have four in the party so
just pick your four favorite characters
right well this one it was like you only
have these guys and they were [ __ ] and
annoying characters
yeah so it was like what am i supposed
to [ __ ] do this game sucks oh that's
not a good jlpg
and then like one of the main enemies
just a snake coiled in like a [ __ ]
and the whole joke was that it was a
piece of [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
that sounds hilarious what it's a piece
of [ __ ]
it's a metaphor for the game
i'm still annoyed about it i completed
it and i loved playing it but i
literally only played it because
it was like i bought this game my mum
won't buy me another one so i have to
completely
i need to play this now i want you to
play just so you can like
how did you get that game again so what
it was is like you know i don't know if
your game stores had this but in the uk
they had a
three for 20 pounds pre-owned games oh
yeah yeah
so i would basically just go to the
thing and buy three games that looked
okay
yeah yeah and then i would just be
forced to play them most of the time
they were all like super easy and you
had an absolute gold like blue dragon
there was like there was like one of
each game and there's a whole [ __ ]
shelf of blue dragons just like take him
take him honestly like for free
honestly it comes with the badge was it
like a was it like a
well-received game at all or like it was
very mid-tier like
like five out of ten six hours this was
my first time ever having to swap discs
to progress with the story and that [ __ ]
pissed me off holy [ __ ]
yeah i remember that i just remembered
something all right um
okay i get rid of
gears of war no that was a good pace
that's a good pick no no no
subnautica okay i'll get rid of
subnautica yeah
um i just remembered something uh put
fifa09
what the [ __ ] i just [ __ ] remembered
i was [ __ ]
i got i was i had a period in my life
where i was obsessed with fifa
i i am i am not joking also smoking
cigarettes on a corner
and flying footy okay this is this is
during the university
you know you're you're in a british
university everyone plays are you
refused and be like no
no i'm gonna play anything else [ __ ]
this game
i just remembered something i i i was
one of the top 200 players
of fifa at a point yeah yeah yeah i'm
not joking
i'm not joking there's like oh this is
like just giving me flashbacks this is
like conor coming out that it used to be
like a chord pro
it's like god used to be a female 09
person so how are you how are you the
top 200 how did it work
like rankings yeah it's it's like
ranking it's it's it's a literal ranking
system
and i it got to the point where i was
just i just got myself on the
leaderboards
of of fifa that's how i did it
because i was just obsessed with the
game and like everyone started playing
it so i'm just like
oh i i guess i'll play fifa did you
demolish everyone
in like your unidorm yeah pretty much
because
because here's the thing because uh like
my my group of mates um
and my unidorm uh they were like super
super competitive over fifa right
it was like they were like that in mind
and this is how you get bragging rights
there was two games it was cod and fifa
and
i was just to me it was just like fifa
was not like watching football at all
fifa was just like
the ball goes yeah and um
and yeah i don't know i just got really
good at it and i don't know how because
um yeah i mean just the british in you
yes well yeah there was two games
because i [ __ ] i i
i i feel like it was one game where i
got good at really unintentionally
and it was probably the only game i've
ever played in my life that i got good
at unintentionally
and i don't really like football that
much what's wrong with you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i don't
know 200 in the world
like i hate this game
the fact is like i had completely
blanked that from my memory until it was
like
just now yeah full time i'm just like
how the [ __ ] did that happen how the
[ __ ] would i get top 200 in
in the um yeah i top 200 in fifa and i'm
just like
yeah i just played it and i just kept
ranking up and then i just got really
bored
and i stopped playing because and the
reason i stopped playing was because
i finished uni and i didn't have a
reason to play it anymore
wow no because i remember now how it
started because i got the game literally
just to blend in with the normies so i i
literally got the game so
i could have something to talk to people
about at parties right
and so i'm one of them he literally
bought fifa as a social gimmick
yeah yeah yeah so i started playing it
so i could like keep up my mates and
everything
and then i just kind of figured out a
meta
i guess because you know it's football
everyone wants to score goals and then i
quickly realized
if you just learned how to defend
correctly and if you just
could defend goods you are better than
90
of players that ever played that game
because everyone only wants to score
goals and then so after that so i've
so after that then i figured out the
broken teams and the broken team was
barcelona
because they were the best team in the
world at the time but then so most
people were picking barcelona
and then i realized that there was a
counter to barcelona which was into
milan
because inter milan had uh zlatan
ibrahimovic
and um he just completely destroyed the
barcelona defense because
he couldn't be shaken off the ball
that's the swedish guy right yeah that's
the swedish guy
yeah yeah he in the game he was
completely [ __ ] broken so
your life here was completely broken so
then once i realized that i just thought
i just started like just started beating
all my mates and then i was just like
you know what let's just let me let's
just limit test myself how far i can
how far can i get up with this and you
know i said top 200 earlier i'm not sure
if it's top 200 it's up 300 but like
one of the one of the top still
impressive yeah yeah one one of the top
few hundreds in
uh in the game at the time um and i just
kept i just kept playing until
i stopped climbing and yeah that's
that's how far i climbed and then
like i just casually told one of my one
of my mates that and he's just like have
you ever thought about entering
competitions or stuff like that and i'm
just like
no no i don't think i will because
because uh yeah i just wanted to make
anime reviews and watch anime at the
time so i just like
had no interest in playing that game in
my own in my own time takes off adidas
tracksuit
and uh yeah i just i just remember that
now so uh i don't know what reminds me
of that
topic that was like pre the before the
uh fifa ultimate team
nonsense yeah that was before fifa
ultimate i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on right now
yeah so like right now like i think if
you want to have
a legitimate competitive team in fifa
you need a team
of a value of around 27 000 real
money like dollars jesus that's how much
you on average have to spend
to have an actual like top competitive
team why so all the pros have spent like
thirty thousand dollars plus
so okay [ __ ] hell okay just just to
compete this is this is gonna sound so
weird
after everything i've i've just said um
what's fifa ultimate
basically they you know again this is a
hundred percent like and imagine an
alien describing how humans converge
i've never played this myself but
obviously i'm a gamer
so i like to keep up with games yeah um
but yes so essentially one of those is
micro transactions like imagine anime
like you know
because fate you can you go against each
other in fate like no p
no no so imagine a pvp fate where you
can build a team
just so happens instead of like you know
two or three characters it's like a team
of like 11
or whatever it is i think so it's
literally fifa gotcha well yeah it's
like
they're the ones who like this this is
the reason why it started like it got so
bad like because
so it's literally pay to win it's 100
pay to win and so like to even
so to be like to be able to compete
competitively
you have to have it the stacked team to
get the stacked team you spend on
average like 30
to even have a chance of getting the
stacked team dude that's that's [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] and like you you hear
even the pros
talk about it like there's interviews
with them where they're like yeah it's
not fun at all
like you have to spend this amount of
money and everyone's playing the same
[ __ ] because everyone has the same
broken [ __ ] yeah
everyone yeah yeah it's so [ __ ] like
you know we we sit here and complain
about gacha and it's like yeah okay you
know at
the end of the day it is 90 of the time
you're not
you're not playing against other people
and that's where it starts to get real
when when when you start playing against
other people that's right well that's
where i draw them
yeah because because because you're like
oh i i you know i could beat this person
or i could i could have won this event
if i just had that extra broken gap
because
because the way i see it is that with
gacha you with the gacha games i play
you're playing against a computer or
you're playing through to get content
um if you come if it becomes pvp then
you are
kind of making someone else's day worse
by paying more you know
definitely you're making someone else's
gaming experience worse
because you played more and that's
that's where i draw the line yeah
because i used to i don't know which
game i played i think i
found it on like mini clip or something
this is like when i first started
earning my own money
and there was like a game where it was
kind of like one of those like you
kind of like what's that clash of clans
like the really popular mobile game
one where you build your own fort on
your square the map yeah yeah
yeah yeah but it takes like days for
their army to arrive
so this is like before even that was out
i was playing a game similar to that on
like mini clip or some [ __ ]
and then like i remember i was playing
this game and i thought i was doing
pretty well i
i only spent like 20 bucks and i was
like oh this is i'm doing pretty good
for myself hey
and then literally like a guy who had
like the [ __ ] like
just perfect like putin's palace worth
of [ __ ]
just came in and just one shot my entire
thing that i'd spent months building
yeah just because he clearly was like he
had like just oil money
or something this man had everything in
the game which must have been like 50k
worth of stuff and just killed me and i
was like i was like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] imagine peter winning a
mini club game
i was like i felt bad that i spent 20
bucks on it because i was like i was
like 18. and i was like
a lot of money and i was like this
[ __ ]
wiped out not only the hours that i put
in but the 20 bucks that i put in were
wiped out and i couldn't [ __ ] do
anything
yeah i had to sit there and watch his
army coming for five days
and then you can drop down the menu see
this man's army the man had sent like
the equivalent of like everything they
thought in 300 against me and i'm
literally like it's like the [ __ ]
persian
yeah i'm literally there with like my
[ __ ] like stick men
like ready and i'm seeing this army come
like four weeks ahead and i'm like
[ __ ] okay like mom get the credit card
what am i supposed to do this is so
funny oh my god and a lesser man would
have been like i can win this
unless a man would have thought i could
out i could outbid this man
so this is why people hate micro
transactions yeah i get it now i
understand gamers that's i think
from that moment on as i slowly saw that
man's army
approach me the resentment built every
day to the point where i was like i
can't
this is [ __ ] i'm just watching my work
be destroyed
so well i i guess going back to the fifa
ultimate thing i'm curious like
how do people even become pros does that
mean you have like
you have to legit be good at it i mean
you know literally drop a house deposit
oh you have to be good and also have
disposable income yeah to become a pro
and fifa older than i guess
isn't it sad that when you're going to a
tournament there's probably some people
at that tournament who like
need that money to recruit the money
they put in just to like isn't that sad
oh that is that that is [ __ ] like okay
you know
you know normally you know if you're if
you're an amazing fighting game player
all you got to worry about is the
the hotel getting there and you know
making sure you have enough to live
which is all okay which is difficult
enough yeah but you add on that of like
oh so i spent 50k on peach like to
to enter this map you know what i mean
it's like this is ridiculous it's so
[ __ ] i feel bad for the like the
people playing fifa who like genuinely
like the game you have to deal with the
[ __ ]
yeah i didn't i didn't know he had a
competitive scene at all because i i
mean i stopped playing
after after like oh nine ten and i'm
just like okay that that
that is behind me i literally blanked it
from my memory so got out
i got out i got a choice shall we move
on gentlemen yeah we're an hour in we
should get yeah we should get moving
on pull out trash taste cooling again
and see uh who's going
to pick joey sure okay next is corner
wow we literally did this again
we went in order last time i put these
two back in yeah all right pull mine up
put it up
all right check this out all right i'm
i'm ready for
a lot of toxic gaming right here i'm
ready for a lot of pro gaming
i have reasons behind all my picks here
okay and also i think some of them
you'll be like yeah so they'll be like
what the [ __ ] wrong with you
all right all right here we go [ __ ]
check this [ __ ] out check the [ __ ]
okay check this [ __ ] out some good
okay there's some here that i was like
all right fully expecting yeah
fully expected some of them okay i'm
gonna have to give you points for
uh the the middle three there yeah bro
especially the very middle one
i was not expecting from you super mario
strikers is like if you played that game
as a kid you know you're in the middle
it is
so good it is legit like it is an actual
crime fifa oh no that ain't got [ __ ] oh
yeah was here being pro at fifa i was
here [ __ ] clapping my friend's cheeks
with the super smashes
bro super mario strike is right if
you've played this game you'll know
exactly why this is on here yeah this
[ __ ] is god tier
like everyone who's played this game
[ __ ] loves it the original gamecube
one right it's yeah yeah it's
so good and it's an actual crime we
don't have this on twitter have you that
it was that one and also
sloggers as well the baseball one so oh
my god oh my god you just hit me with
the stars
sloggers super mario sluggers gamecube
is so good
i had a [ __ ] ordeal trying to get
sluggers on the wii oh really
really um so what happened with was is
that what i saw sluggers somewhere
online i was like mom i want this and it
was only available from like
taobao or something on china right like
so my mom bought it from china
right for me for christmas and it was
like the one game that i really wanted
that christmas
and i put it in and then obviously the
wii has um
that that has that what's uh region oh
the region log yeah so i played it and i
was like why isn't it working mom and
obviously my parents have no [ __ ]
idea
is that like what is it we bought you
the game it's the game why isn't it
working i mean
they didn't figure it out either and so
they sent it back and bought another one
from china again because for some some
reason it didn't it wasn't out in europe
for some reason oh really i think if it
hadn't released yet because you know
back then it was like for some reason
they would leave six months between yeah
the police and uh
europe and australia were always lost
once together yeah yeah yeah because
you'd have to see all these youtube
videos you're like i know this exists
why can't i buy it
and so i had no whole ordeal i never got
to play it in the end even though
really two or three times i played
sliders at my friend's place and i had
the most fun i've ever played in a mario
spin-off game i think yeah what is
sluggers there's the baseball
baseball one yeah i think that the mario
strikers is the best mario spinoff game
well strikers there's
strikers they're sluggers and then
there's uh mario three on three
basketball as well oh my god
yes do you know that one i never played
that but
dude legit i feel i feel like you're
just naming mario party mini games
dude honestly all of the sports
spin-offs of mario are all
such [ __ ] solid games like mario
tennis [ __ ] solo
mario golf [ __ ] solid i think i legit
would put like strikers like
uh like up there with mario kart like
main line yeah
i would i think it's that good like like
to me it's like yeah
okay of course i like sunshine gone yeah
of course i like all this game
but like mario strikers that's when
you're woke you're like
i'm listening like if your mates like
you want to play strikers you're like
[ __ ] yet
yeah because it was always like you know
are they you know because there was this
mechanic and it was probably the funnest
mechanic in a mario game where like yeah
you so your team would be made of two
main mario characters so you'd have like
you could put like waluigi and then
you'd have like four coopers or
four uh birdos or whatever right yeah
and then he could pick like wario
and so there's this mechanic where you
could choose to do a super shot with the
main character if they had the ball
and it was basically like a quick time
event and you just nail it in like the
perfect like the
the like the be like an arm that would
swing and hit it in the perfect zone
if you got it perfect it would be a
guaranteed goal so it's always a thing
of like
holy [ __ ] can he do it and it was so
hard because the timing is super fast
it's [ __ ] tiny and you have to i
think it's not even guaranteed unless
you're past the halfway point
right if we passed a halfway point to do
it and yeah it's it's [ __ ] it's so
good
it's so [ __ ] good dude but do you
want to go through your
three by three sure sure sure okay okay
i gotta ask first
i know which one you're gonna ask why
what the [ __ ] is battalion wars
okay all right i've never
i've never even heard of it if you look
up battalion wars it's like one of the
highest rated games on like the
at least this one is on the wii and the
first one is one of the highest rated
game dude it is like a really [ __ ]
good strategy game all right
so it's like um so i really like the
online
where it's kind of like um it's kind of
really hard to experience like tanks
no so it was basically like you'd be
given like a set amount of army so you'd
be given maybe like three tanks
four long range tanks ten uh ground
units and there would be a mission
and so the the way that it worked is
like you would have to try and
take over or take over a base or push
push the enemy out
without losing as many people as
possible but the online was really good
it was essentially
the same thing but one person was
defending a point and the other person
had a push
right and it was really fun cause i got
really [ __ ] good at it when i was
like 15
and i would just keep winning and i
would like cheese people with strats and
stuff it's such a good game
i played so [ __ ] much of that game
it's so good because i've never heard of
this game right and i look at this cover
and i'm just like this looks like some
chinese knockoff game like
dude this is like the mom
i want advanced wars we have advanced
wars at home can we zoom in can we zoom
in on this yeah
you can see you can see the cover here
right now oh dude it's good dude it's so
good check out gameplay
okay probably i'm just i'm not because
i'm just like genuinely curious why i've
never heard of this game before yeah
it's kind of like um i don't know how to
explore because it's like
it plays somewhat similar to halo wars
but but quite different like oh
that's it as well so i completely forgot
one of the main mechanics of the game
so imagine a real-time strategy where
you can be like give me con
first person control of this guy yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] get on the ground and
do the work yeah
so you can swap between the units of who
you're doing first person right
so because sometimes obviously the
automation is like good yeah you can
obviously be way more
like in control and do more damage so
like the like
you know because there's tanks there's
planes there's whatever like the planes
were okay but if you went first person
you could really [ __ ]
[ __ ] people up with them yeah and you
could dodge [ __ ] way easier and stuff
like that
dude it's so good anyone who played
battalion wars 2 will know it
no no i'm just realizing that we went
through my entire three by three
talked talked about it for an hour and
not once did i use the term mechanic
that's all gameplay mechanic i'm just
like oh yeah it gave me the mechanic so
that's the selling point of games
right didn't didn't mention that once
throughout my entire three by three
one thing that's going to be definitely
i guess throughout all of my nine is
that like i really think they have like
super like strong game mechanics no no i
look at this and i'm just like yeah
a lot of these have really strong
gameplay loops like guitar hero
[ __ ] of course yeah of course like i you
know me
music isn't my thing i like i like beeps
and boobs but guitar hero three i played
the [ __ ] out of that trying to get like
i think everybody who had that game
played the [ __ ] out legit i can't even
remember the amount of times i attempted
through the fire and flames
and like just to like think that i was
good and then watch someone on youtube
like a 10 year old crush me
perfect dude because that was always the
game as well like no matter what person
like if they were like i'm not into
gaming it's like no no i've got guitar
hero they're like all right i'm down
yeah and so like that was that was just
like such a great game and also i really
value being a game
that is so good at getting people who
don't game into it
that's so underrated i mean who doesn't
game nowadays though well i
i i could get my parents to play guitar
hero with me true true which is like
like think of how many games you could
like i'm not my parents i want to play
[ __ ] battalion wars too
like how do i like yeah dad okay so
we're gonna do is you're gonna take
first person control of this plane and
then uh you've got to push for the base
no my dad's gonna be like [ __ ] off son
if he sees me clapping cheeks with this
guitar
but i want to try that out yeah and he
did and it was great there's the one
time where you could be like my parents
give a [ __ ] about my hobby
but they don't it's like
okay but the thing is did you own guitar
hero 3 um okay
because like i only won guitar though i
couldn't afford it
because his thing like i love playing
rhythm games i love playing especially
with like when
when we're at the arcade and everything
like that i love playing rhythm games
i've always
loved the feeling playing rhythm games
i've never like gotten to the point when
i'm like
okay i'm going to own a rhythm game now
i'm going to practice a rhythm game i
mean when guitar hero was out man they
were like
they were [ __ ] everywhere it was so
easy to get like knock-off guitar
ones and stuff like it was like before
rock band came along is when the hype
started dying but like it was
everyone had rock yeah guitar hero yeah
yeah
i'm sad because like i feel the fact
that i
started learning how to actually play
guitar kind of threw me off playing
guitar hero
because like i would like watch people
play guitar hero and i'd play it as well
and i'd be like this is really fun
but i could also just be playing a
guitar
people who don't like instruments yeah
right right exactly and even now like i
still enjoy watching like that
uh that twitch streamer who plays guitar
custom songs
yeah yeah yeah like i love like
everything about guitar just seems so
fun
oh yeah yeah it's great i mean i think
it's a banger what are you learning
where's the score system how do i get
ranked you know it's none of those
like people who play sports games hate
playing sports
well you know what other other rhythm
game could have been on here that i
i i didn't play the rhythm game but i
played the other game of it was uh
donkey konger oh yeah yeah yeah
basically donkey kong
the donkey kong bongos on gamecube
jungle beat right jungle beat yeah
i thought was way better than the um uh
the actual
rhythm game one yeah game one which was
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but then they
had like a platformer
yeah that was using the bongos yeah did
you see this yeah no jungle b was
[ __ ] awesome you would like platform
and then like you would you'd like so if
you clapped at a certain thing and then
if you like hit both it would do a
certain
oh no i remember literally replacing the
controller with like two points
and it played so well like you think it
wouldn't and then like sometimes the
the boss fights were like [ __ ]
clapping battles yeah it was so cool
man the game was so good that could be
on here as well so
for me it was like only that one rich
kid who had that game and everyone was
like wait you have it without end up
coming over well that was because like i
played uh
the rhythm game one at my friend's house
and i was like mom please get me this
for christmas
and then i like at the time i i kind of
really regretted it because
to me it was like i paid like three
times the price of a video game
right for just one game yeah and it was
good but i was like oh it's over now
yeah because for me it was a choice
between jungle beat or
taika and like i got taiko obviously
because it was like
there's more places it was more for me i
think my problem with rhythm games is
that i have a hard time
looking at it as anything but a party
game right
and because like i i understand people
getting getting into rhythm games but i
cannot play a rhythm game for more than
like a few songs before i'm just like
okay i
i think one thing that rhythm games i
quite like even though i don't like
instruments or care about music much is
that
i really like the uh you can always like
feel like you're improving
even when you replay a song or like when
you're going through you always feel
like you're improving i i'll tell you
what like rhythm games are it's
it's feeling like you're playing an
instrument without going through the
boring parts
yeah like my god like imagine imagine if
you could just learn how to play guitar
without having to do scales
right like wait there's only five
buttons yeah
that's so easy you mean i don't i don't
have to like practice scales five times
like
like five times every time just one
rhythm game i didn't put in my
three by three but i could easily put it
on there is um rhythm heaven
you know that game on the ds i played
the [ __ ] it i played that game
so much that i snapped two ds styluses
while playing that game holy [ __ ] snap i
didn't know this thing
yeah because i was like so [ __ ]
concentrated on it that like i literally
was like
there's a [ __ ] crap yes just impaled
like the stick comes out the other side
legit i played like the reason why my
original ds broke was because i played
too much rhythm here
oh my god because it got to the point
where like my touch pad was like
you've damaged me like so much so that
the inside is just [ __ ] now and
nothing responded
it's it's like your ds is just like that
anime character who's just like
who's like gone through hell and just
has been like battered and bruised no
dude my my ds [ __ ] like the touch pad
on my ds just looked like bucky's body
it was just like [ __ ]
it was just like shattered it's like
this guy's been through like a thousand
years old
so much guns in it yeah oh dude it was
[ __ ] oh my god i had so much fun
playing rhythm evan any other questions
um i mean everything's sonic rider yes
listen i know this is gonna get flat
right i'm surprised this wasn't the
immediate thing that i was giving flag
for right
right i'm just shocked there's a sonic
game honestly like
i didn't give you flack because i was
actually really close to putting sonic
adventure 2 on my
no sonic battle adventure 2 yeah yeah
that was that was that was that easily
could have been on here
running around at the speed of sound
just for like me like
me like giving like my chows like
steroids
[ __ ] in there drag him up do the race
i love that that was so fun um yeah i
mean like sonic riders was like the one
game
that because it came with my gamecube
right so when i bought the gamecube it
was when it was
already dying and they were just
literally trying to sell it with
anything so i got like um
a bunch of free games with my gamecube
for like very cheap
and sonic riders was the one that i
hated most that came with this game
right i was like
i was like these controls suck dick it
is one of the most janks
it's like so [ __ ] jank right and like
the the learning curve for this game the
mechanics seemed completely like
overkill
like a kids game yeah but then after
like i actually sat down and like just
for like 20 hours didn't understand the
game and like eventually understood what
was happening
this game felt so [ __ ] clean like it
felt so good
i felt that way with uh kirby's air ride
as well because
for the first like 10 hours i was like
wait it's not just a racing game yeah
what the [ __ ] is this i have to like
earn my ride and then go into what the
right right because there was like this
like glide mechanic where you had to
like jump in the other person's like
trail yeah it was completely jank and it
would like throw you out and stuff and
it was
so gent but it was like probably the one
game where
my impressions on it completely 180'd
after i like actually put time into it
right i got good at it and i was like
wait
this is a [ __ ] clean game and i
played it so goddamn much i played this
game
so i was glad to know that i'm not the
only one who has like a 3d sonic game as
like a guilty pleasure game
dude yeah it was like for me it was
sonic heroes
i i could have personally yeah and i
didn't put in my 3x3 just because like
if i did
i know people will be like you put a 3d
sonic game no
dude i could i could put some honestly
like i i defend it i i have
no like fond memories of any 2d sonic
games but it's the 3d sonic games
i have fun i remember i tried it look
because it's
there's one reason because i was a
nintendo kid through and through so
sonic wasn't available till the gamecube
okay that's why
exactly that's why listen sonic right
this is a good game
if you if you learn listen like if you
watch people play it for the first time
they'll be like this is [ __ ] garbage
yeah this is the worst game ever but
then if you see someone who's good at it
you're like damn that looks [ __ ] good
no legit it's a good game no it is a
good game i played it
that's why i'm glad to know that like
i'm not the only one who's like you know
what there are good sonic games like
special
sonic heroes if i replayed it probably
jank as [ __ ] oh yeah i probably hate the
[ __ ] out of it i'm like i remember that
casino level i [ __ ] hated
in that game but i enjoyed sonic i
remember you just keep dying randomly
from stuff in there yeah it was
it was one of the most i don't think it
was a [ __ ] game yeah i don't think i've
played sonic heroes but i've definitely
played
some 3d sonic games and i've actually
enjoyed most of them
it's it's [ __ ] i mean i mean i mean
black ops is self-explanatory
black ops 2 that is i think even though
i played i
couldn't tell you the difference well
there's a big there's a massive
difference okay okay
okay there's you know as if any you know
which one's the one where it literally
starts off with the airport getting shot
up
that's moderate that's my extent
of knowledge of course when that came
out that was such a big deal like oh
yeah it was a huge idea
my mom like she'd already bought me the
game and then she was like
connor i've heard about this thing in
this game where you kill a bunch of
people at an airport
i didn't buy you that game did i and i
was like no no no
she was like oh okay good good good
no russian no yeah modern warfare 2 is
the one that i probably played the most
modern warfare 3 is one where i won a
bunch of free [ __ ] yeah
and then black ops 2 was probably the
one i had most fun with and that i
played competitively like in teams and
stuff and i really enjoyed
yeah it was so fun it was so clean yeah
that game they like optimized it it was
like the best card 100 hands down
the maps were the best the multiplayer
had like a good rank system which they'd
never had before
i don't think they ever put back in like
it was legit good it was such a it was
just a [ __ ] great game
fantastic [ __ ] game anyone who likes
card will tell you that black ops 2 is
the best game yeah that's that's
what i hear most of the time it's like
it's either black ops 2 or modern
warfare you're like this is all noise to
me
is is this how it feels when we talk
about music
probably i'm i'm like i'm like cool oh
yeah
like it's has it got the people the most
balanced you know it's it's just a great
game
it's just the game and i i put way too
many hours and it's what got me into
like competitive gaming and i like
really that was like the first esports i
started watching
i just had like a really good tournament
okay um but then all the [ __ ] pro
players like weird
as [ __ ] at that time they were just like
yeah it was weird it was very strange
and then i'm not surprised you have time
crisis and metal slug in there because
yeah whenever we go to an arcade
together and that you have metal gear or
not
so metal slugs all right see you later
metal slug i have
always just been obsessed with other
places uh that's battles like acts i
think i think
i think metals like x is like the best
game overall
um if you don't know what metal slug is
it's a neo geo game that was really
popular in arcades and you can probably
still find it in a lot of arcades
um it's aged super [ __ ] well oh it
looks so
like the sprite work on it for its time
was like insane yeah like and it
looks like it's still almost insane and
it's got like some of the best [ __ ]
sound effects the
rocket launcher i love that [ __ ]
the gameplay is so goddamn clean in that
game yeah it doesn't overstay its
welcome it's like his six levels enjoy
them get the [ __ ] out
did you ever enjoy contra contra was
really [ __ ] difficult like i mean it
was that's
yeah yeah i think the the reason why i
don't like i think metal slug three
is like probably one of the way too hard
is that like it goes from like you know
level one and two and metal slug three
from being you know a fairly challenging
game
uh to like level uh i think four five
and six just being absolutely [ __ ]
stupid
i mean i remember the first time you and
i ever like game together we played all
three of the middle slogging games back
if with two people who played the game
you could easily breeze through it and
then we got the three
yeah and we were like [ __ ] this game
it's so hard
three like there is it is like you have
to play that game
every absurd amount because even if you
know where all the enemies are spawning
and where they're coming from it's like
it doesn't matter because there's just
so much [ __ ]
it's literally yeah yeah it's complete
[ __ ] i just did it just to [ __ ]
[ __ ] with you and take your money i just
realized there should have been another
game on my
three by three i'm like we're talking
about this uh mega man x
oh my god yeah like i'm thinking i was
thinking like side scrollers i
completely forgot how much i was
obsessed with sci-fi i was i was
tossing up between mega man x and mega
man 2 right yeah just
purely mega man x is just [ __ ] it's
it's like it still feels like anime
right it's got
it's got such an anime story line yeah
um but
my god like the the gameplay in that is
clean as well
i forgot how much i loved hard games as
a kid yeah man i really [ __ ] now i was
like
hey yeah please because i'm like
man yeah i remember i completed contra
um
super contra at least on the snes
without without the contra code uh yeah
without the controversy my cousin i'm
hardcore gamer right yeah i'm just like
what
i remember completing mega man and that
was really easy what the [ __ ] happened
to me man
yeah because i was exactly the same like
i i haven't beaten contra without the
conjurer code yeah but like i
i remember like how easy it was for me
to be like mega man 2. i could be in
like an
hour and like you know a lot i think
last year the year before
i was like i want to stream some retro
games oh i'll play mega man 2. because i
played that like [ __ ] crazy yeah dude
i got like 30 minutes in i only beat
like two like [ __ ] robo boss i'm like
this game is [ __ ] impossible how did
i beat this as like a 10 year old you
should have patience man
yeah but no because yeah okay go for it
but like stuff with like contra like i
never played as a kid so when i play now
and like just [ __ ] kills you because
there's a lot of [ __ ]
right like yeah i'm just immediately
turned off from [ __ ] like that yeah
no this is just [ __ ] it's it's weird
because i i'm just like
this conversation has brought back so
many memories about how
how much patience i had as a kid yeah
because i remember another game that was
uh people complained about being super
hard and super [ __ ] he was battle
toads
um it was the level with the bikes right
yeah
yeah yeah i i still remember the level
with the bikes and having to complete
that and completing battle toes and i'm
just like
man i remember i i think i just blanked
it out because there was just so many
hours of my life that were just some
[ __ ] level yeah and i just
as a kid you were just mind-numbingly
just like [ __ ] learnt it through um
through muscle memory right right and
i would not have the patience to do that
anymore like if it was like you value
your time
you're like if there's something like
because battle told by the battle toads
let's be honest is [ __ ]
yeah yeah full of [ __ ] but i [ __ ]
love that game
yeah but because you can't you can't
play that now and be like this is
fantastic it's like ninja gaiden for me
as well yeah
that game is just free yeah where it's
like i remember i almost beat that game
as a kid and i got to like i think like
the second to last level now i can't
even get past level one yeah and i
remember
like i'm trying to think about how the
[ __ ] did i be mega man x
on the [ __ ] snez controller right my
god i remember getting like cramps and
carpool tunnel
from like the like like tapping the jump
button on the wall
like again some of the bosses right at
least it's not as bad as a nest
controller
that thing was [ __ ] awful in your
hands
yeah yeah i i just think for me metal
slug
is the best age just a best overall
uh running guns i think i think it's one
of the one of the games that's like age
the best i feel like if you look at any
like any indie game that comes out now
that is like a side scroller running gun
it just it looks so inspired by metals
oh yeah my work is like identical yeah
it's it's like the blueprint of like
this is how you make a clean
running gun yeah it's you know metal
slug you know
three is [ __ ] um but like one two
and x
i mean x is just kind of two yeah like
one two and x like i would highly
recommend getting x i think it's on
steam one and two are also
on steam you can get all of them yeah go
and get it it's such a fun game
um it's just great this is when you play
with someone else right yeah yeah it's
so funny yeah it's so difficult
as well so it's just a great game i mean
it's clean yeah and
i'm on crisis man okay some [ __ ] like
the original one i think is such a
goddamn
gem of a game when you go to an arcade
you see i still think time crisis is
good and the only reason i could never
progress
too far in time crisis was because i
never had enough money yeah
yeah so like i think once you get over
that point of time crisis where you've
beaten it a few times
you can beat the whole game at least
game one on one credit like pretty much
pretty easily yeah because you know
you know when all the bullshit's coming
and to me when i used to play because
like you know when you're when you would
go to an arcade right because we i would
stay in like france for like i don't
know two weeks at a time yeah my parents
would give me like two euros a day
maybe how did you complete the game the
first time which is what i wanted yeah
i've i've like no matter what i i have
always run out of money yeah i feel i
feel like the first time you played time
crisis if you only had like two credits
right yeah you could
maybe get possible you know maybe up to
like stage two so this was like
something over like years
where it was like i would always even
like see it in arcades and i would
always pick it up and then
maybe if i had two weeks i would play it
like every day for two weeks right
or i would like you know and as well i
got to the point where it
when when okay if you had your name on
the high score
all of them so i would go and try and
take all 10 slots when i would go
when i would go to like a vacation point
again because i would be there for like
two weeks so i'm like oh what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna take every single
slot on this thing yeah but then i um
and so eventually what you could what i
would do is
i would be like if someone was gonna
play it i would just like i would just
chill out and i'd be like oh that's me
by the way
and then they would be like oh yeah they
would be like oh you want to play with
me
i'm like hell yeah give me your credit
and they'd give me a credit right and i
could just play
you literally game the system no yeah
but then but then it was [ __ ]
because some people uh some of the
systems when they pulled out the plug at
night like it would wipe all the high
schools that was like my worst nightmare
because i would i would get the high
score
yeah you know feel real good i'd come
back the next day and i'm like
where is it where is my high school my
street cred
gone just like that i'm like no how did
you prove that that name was you though
that's what i want to know people just
took your word for it
um that's a good question how did they
do i guess it's just the old system
right of just people just took your word
for it
yeah i guess the moment they i put the
coin and i started [ __ ] just
destroying everyone they'd be like i
think it's him
it's you know this the old speed run
rules right like you don't need you
don't we don't need video proof we
trust that you say well because like if
you're a rookie right time
they'd go like this you know i would
just like so i would like get yeah
and then like flick it off like that
excuse you in time crisis right that's
good
so yeah because the way right i learned
right i'm like wait the the normal way
of shooting so
if you i'm assuming most people who are
watching this have seen or played a time
crisis if you haven't it's the one where
you put your pedal down
on the thing and then you pop out to
shoot that should be enough to let you
know i mean i assume if you've left your
house been to an arcade or
anything or then bowling you've seen
this thing it's it's [ __ ] basically
it's the best arcane
uh arcade game you can play you don't
live in japan yeah and i realized right
after a while i'm like right
if you're doing the whole like holding
it with two hands pointing shooting your
finger isn't fast enough and the way the
time crisis worked with points is that
you had to
like there would be this like a smash
combo right when you
shot a character first there was like a
split second where you could keep
shooting them with bullets
to get more points and combo it so if
you shot someone once that's it you only
got like 10 points
you could unload like eight bullets into
one person so what you'd have to do is
when they would all pop up on screen you
have to get like max amount of points on
each person on screen right so i would
unload the whole mag into one character
so that's how you had to be like a man
just like discovered turbo mode no yes
it was literally like imagine like i
literally just learned the technique of
like spamming this thing like this i
would like to twitch my
absolutely like oh [ __ ] like and then i
would do it for everyone on the screen
and so that way no one came close to
beating me in school
yeah yeah and then i would remember the
points where like i think a time crisis
one
or two there's a point where you get a
machine gun and if you you could like
juggle the cover
so that you could keep your combo even
while going in cover mm-hmm so you could
like juggle it to get an absurd combo
this man at age 10 is optimizing games
so i remember this
speech like literally like age 13
and then like it was like yeah in maxing
time crisis yeah i
i loved it and then you know then you
start playing time crisis three and four
so two was nice two is when they
introduced like sorry i'm gonna go into
in depth yeah no no no no no no no
so time crash is one all you had was the
pistol yeah and you could do
boom time guys two they started
introducing like weird [ __ ] like machine
gun grenade
shotgun you're like all right whatever
cool time guys is threes where they
start getting [ __ ] weird with it and
they start introducing all this dumb
[ __ ] and now we're on like seven
yeah and it's just garbage like it's
[ __ ] game where you just get [ __ ]
shot it's like it's like house of the
dead well you were playing five the
other day and you said five was all
right
it's okay but like they introduced like
they i feel like they they did what
house of the dead did
like where house of the dead was an
amazing arcade game one was
pretty challenging two was quite
difficult and they started adding a few
things that were like that's true that's
cheeky that and three onwards they just
started adding [ __ ] that would just kill
you yeah like unless you literally like
perfect headshot yeah everything yeah
because you've played it right yeah and
there's times where you're literally
hitting everything on house of the dead
and it's just like it doesn't matter
yeah just [ __ ] dead and it's like
this game [ __ ] sucks dick [ __ ] this
game you just took my money and i don't
like it i'm a good guy
literally you're literally that kid you
know in persona 5. you know the kid in
the arcade yeah like teaches you the gun
moves
that's literally i'm i'm just sitting
here i'm i'm just thinking i don't think
i've heard connor talk more passionately
about something
like since i've been friends with this
time crisis
crisis is the best game and i also had
it on ps2
so that also helped okay wow that was
the next stage up right so i had i had
time gracious two
on the ps2 and so when i went to the
arcade i was like it's just like the
simulations
like i've been waiting to use that meme
it was literally like that because i was
like i already know exactly when is the
optimization
i i know all the levels off by [ __ ]
matrix
well that was the thing as well it's
like because because you were like you
were broke and you didn't have credits
you i would legit like
it was the same thing with metal slug i
would be like i would just go up to the
kids and i'm like
hey i'm really [ __ ] good at this if
you give me a credit i'll help you get
really far and then you'll be like oh
okay sure
because then it was a win-win because
even though i was doing all the work
they felt like they were getting an
extra 15 minutes of fun
where they would have got two yeah you
know what i mean i mean that's that's
the thing right where
you know that i mean i guess arcade
games were the original pay to win
yeah because you know
like like i never met a single person
who had completed time crisis because
how the [ __ ]
does any kid my age complete time yeah i
would like i would like have a fit
in my head if i even got hit once in
time crisis after a while because i was
like i knew where they all should have
been coming this man is trying to know
hit time
well it was like it was so fun because
after like you said right you're not
supposed to that the games weren't
designed for you to play it this much
yeah but this is also why they started
upping the difficulty of arcades because
people would just
sit there all day yeah and complete
games on one dollar and get 30 minutes
when they should have been getting two
minutes
and so that's why they started upping
you know now it's like all the arcade
games like even the ones that used to be
like pretty fair and used to feel good i
just [ __ ] like yeah like the mario
kart arcade game now [ __ ] that game
sucks you get one race
it's shitty you know like if you were
doing like daytona back in the day
if you were [ __ ] good at that game
you kept to get you kept playing because
you kept getting to the checks points
yeah
right but now it's like you get one race
[ __ ] off that was three dollars it's
like
no just because you got to take a
picture with me and put it on the
character you think that's enough to
keep me happy
oh [ __ ] off mario this is [ __ ] yeah
although to be fair every time i see
that and i'm with like three other
people i'm like they always want to play
it
you play it and then every time you play
it you're like all right
yeah because people want to play because
it's mario kart
yeah it plays worse than the actual
mario kart yeah how do they do that it's
supposed to be better what the [ __ ]
i'm so passionate about because arcade
games suck now
see dog va the fall of arcade games
there's some good verizon for them
you know i think we spoke about it on
the podcast four but typing of the dead
in uh i think i hope it isn't in the one
that closed down because one of the game
centers in akihabara closed down right
right and only one of them had typing of
the dead yeah because you don't know
what typing of that is google it
uh yeah that's good um the jojo battle
royale is okay
yeah it's like a it's like an unreal
engine mod there's it's kind of [ __ ]
yeah yeah there's no real arcade games
now actually it's always the mech one
we even spoke about that have we oh no
the giant mech one
was [ __ ] amazing we don't know what
it's called but here it is
so we know what it looks like you get to
pilot a mac like you literally sit in
the cockpit
you put a seat belt on and there's like
uh gas pedals
drift pedals yeah and it's like 4d
cinema so it actually yeah it moves
it moves as you are flying about so you
are literally
as close to a mecca pilot as you can
possibly be and it's got ranked pvp
so you literally you literally like you
all jump in the mechs with the boys and
you can pvp against other people
literally capture the flag yeah yeah
and it's like domination i think yeah
yeah and yeah you literally like
it's so fun because when you smack down
that thrust and drift pedal
the [ __ ] the chair jumps back yeah it
jumps back and then it's like
like yeah like uh was it like when the
chains going up on the roller coaster
like drifting yeah yeah it's so good
like drifting in the end just firing
missiles at the same time i'm just
dealing with that with the boys you know
switch out the game
and reload the other one as you're
saying oh my god
yeah yeah we're trying to arcade after
some players yeah yeah you come to japan
you've got to check this this is
like everyone says rhythm games no this
is the best arcade game i've played
in japan bar none yeah i believe it's is
it
sega yeah it's saying yeah it's it's
i've already seen it in
a few are like rounds and i saw it in
sega but like yeah
it's actually insane i think it's is it
two dollars or three dollars a play it's
like yeah
two dollars not enough yeah two dollars
a player i think but
one play can last you you know like 15
minutes 15 20 minutes
i'd happily play like pay like five
pounds if it was like in the uk
yeah because my god you get to pilot a
mecca that's so cool
oh god i don't even know what's going on
because i can't read what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] they're saying yeah like i
yeah i love it it's so funny i mean i
can read what they're saying but i don't
give a [ __ ]
it's not important to me all right
before we move on okay like i
i like i i'm wondering why okay before
we get to halo wars i'm wondering why
you put apex over
over league all right okay is this is
this recency bias
i think there's definitely a bit of
recency bias yeah um i don't know for me
league of legends was fun and i really
really really enjoyed the time i had
with it and
it could easily be on here yeah i think
apex is on here just because like
i don't know apex made learning japanese
fun for me
okay like isn't that isn't that fun yeah
because you're actually using it right
yeah and like
for me apex has been such a door opener
like right now like
it's just like everyone's playing apex
right now and like it's so easy to be
like yo player packs let's jump in
you know yeah like uh i don't know just
anyone it's like
especially japanese or like youtubers
it's like yo let's play apex
yeah um i don't know it's so fun and i
feel like it's it's like
even though i just started playing it
recently i have been playing it i did
start playing it at launch
right and i feel like the game's only
gotten bigger and better now and i feel
like that's rare
for games especially battle royale like
i feel like it's more popular now than
ever
yeah yeah and it's [ __ ] massive in
japan
yeah yeah um v cheapers man they they
just completely broke the system yeah
it's crazy i mean you know it's
it's crazy seeing how like when it came
out you know the story of apex is that
they they literally announced apex
legends i don't know if you knew this
a day before it came out oh [ __ ] really
because what happened was is that it was
made by the same people as titanfall
right so ea thought it says published by
yay but it's made by respawn the people
who made titanfall who made call of duty
modern warfare 2 back in the day
so you have that you have that clean fps
gameplay combined with a nutty movement
of titanfall
yeah um and yes so what happened was
that they literally were just like oh by
the way is a new battery owl
and because they thought it was gonna
bomb because it was made by the same
people who
had made titanfall yeah with no titans
in it yeah
and everyone was like yeah i'm not
playing that where the [ __ ] max the
mechs were the best part
yeah but yeah no it was a surprise hit
it [ __ ] blew up the gameplay is so
[ __ ] clean
like i mean i've like from what i heard
apex was just battle royales but just
was
with every mechanic refined it's so good
it's so fun
and you know it's really like weirdly
one of the most beginner-friendly battle
royales i think yeah
what i want to know is has it gotten to
a point where everyone's just really
[ __ ] good at the game yet
no there's a meta and everything's
broken the matchmaking is surprisingly
good like when i play ranked i
really struggle like against people my
own level when i go in like normals if
i'm like playing with uh someone who's
like got a really bad stats it'll like
even us out like i can feel like a god
but you know so in other words yes but
he's on the other side
no no no no no because i'm playing you
know i play with some people who are
like
you know arguably have no hands yeah and
they seem to have the time of their life
right and i'm you know to me i would be
like that's not fun but they seem to you
know they
again people who you know because it's
such a position heavy game it's not
about mechanics
it's more about do like okay are you if
are you standing out in the open and
someone else is on the high ground
shooting at you you're probably gonna
[ __ ] die yeah but like you know
you don't need to have like aim god cs
go [ __ ] that's like i hate that [ __ ]
fortnite felt like that as well like i
feel that like
if you just have like some form of game
knowledge which you can easily learn
you know it's easy and all the
characters are really unique it's really
fun like i don't know it's great i
really think you guys should try it out
try it out with me apex stream literally
every episode every episode i'm gonna
keep saying it until
trash taste apex when it's good like and
legit like i've made so many
new friends from it and yeah like the
other week 47 of asking the boys to play
literally like
and so the other day i actually met up
with people who i met up on apex i met
on apex
with two japanese guys oh really spent
the whole night trying to talk japanese
it was very like taxing
my god i realized i was an hour into
talking only japanese and i was like
[ __ ] i had to do this for like another
four hours of like not being able to
communicate
yeah um it will do wonders though oh no
it was definitely helping like i feel
like i definitely have like the basics
completely locked down like it's all
muscle memory like i could just say [ __ ]
just talk nonsense you know that's good
stuff oh chinchin big you know
all the stuff you need um it's the only
thing that's that matters yeah
yeah it was fun you know it was just
crazy to think that i met these guys
from just chatting [ __ ] on a video game
literally just going in a lobby and
screaming broken japanese
and then i was hanging out with them you
know that's cool yeah it was just chill
like i think it's
all about the friends we made along the
way and honestly
which you can't say about league of
legends exactly i have made friends from
league of legends but like
it just felt like i can't imagine making
a friend from a guy you met in a lobby
in league of legends so
well that's the thing it was always
weird friendships with them like with a
with it because it was always like we
were the same rank we played ranked
together
yeah this weird thing of like that that
was what it was and we were like we our
friendship was
tangential on the fact that we were both
the same rank and we were good enough to
play together
yeah yeah but in apex it's like oh you
know i you know i play with a guy who's
called kyochan he's like a 45 year old
man right from
like west uh japan who's [ __ ] awful
at the game
but he's he's really funny and so like
that's like you know i like playing with
him that's
just like there's no it feels chill it's
a really chill game but it can be a
really intense game if you want it to be
yeah and it's like perfect because it
has like enough lows in it where you can
just talk
and then when the moments where you're
like fighting it's like it's focus on
fighting all right
so that's why it's on there i
legitimately think it's the best battery
i've played i've played so many of them
it deserves to be on there it's a
[ __ ] great game play pex legends
um and finally halo wars i'll quickly
talk about this i played
i have probably put more hours into any
game here uh halo was probably the game
i put most hours into
really why halo wars i don't know what
it was it was me what made me
fall in love with rts's that game was
terribly
unrefined and and awfully unbalanced
yeah
and you know i've never played wars but
that's all i've heard about yeah that is
like
extremely unbalanced i think it was the
case of i was very fortunate that
my my four like i had three best friends
and we all loved halo wars so as a case
of every single day we just went home
and
played halo wars yeah and it was just
like the perfect game to chat to and
also be like
you know all right do this do this yeah
i really like the idea of rts games
i like i mean i i remember playing
command and conquer
so [ __ ] much that was that was my rts
game but i i like i've never got into
rts
like more than just build a bunch of
soldiers and then click on
click on anyone who looks at you funny
that is that that's like my tactics when
it comes to rts games
i think the one thing that i really
loved about halo wars is that it really
did 2v2 and 3v3 well
i can't think of a single rts game that
has 3v3
like can you name it it's always 1v1
yeah and like i find that
like boring yeah like the fact that i
can be there with my mates and we can
all back each other up and then like
yeah you kill one dude's army
[ __ ] his his friend's army is literally
coming to wipe you out and then you're
like bro bring in your army where you at
man where you at
what the [ __ ] that actually sounds
really fun because that's so funny i
guess that's the reason i never
played pvp in any rts even though i know
there is there i just played the
campaign and i'm just like
i can complete the campaign and it's a
chill game because it's like the games
were never more than 20
20 30 minutes they were normally 15 10
minutes so it was great because what
would happen is like
you know there would just be moments
where your mate or there would be like
all three of them would be attacking
your mate
and none of you are ready and you're
like yeah i'll see ya
did i play [ __ ] no like i'm just
realizing my my three by three is a lie
why is red alert two not on my three by
three red look come on and conquer red
lord too
that's a [ __ ] amazing game and not
many people remember it yeah halo wars 2
is pretty good it's on uh you play on pc
it's pretty good does are the
civilization games rts
they're like turn based it's like almost
turn-based right because i really really
like this i played
two like [ __ ] crazy back in the day i
feel like it's in the category it's in
the category it's like a different style
like i play civilization every now and
again because you know when you get that
feeling of just replaying a game every
now and again so
i get that with sieve sometimes and i'm
just like i play one game it lasts it
lasts like eight hours i'm like okay
i've
i'm that's that that that's that's my
one out the window now
i'm satisfied yeah yeah honestly halo
wars is a great game i'm sure if anyone
played it
who like played it with mates i would i
would love to play an rts that's like
2v2 we could play halo wars i mean right
i'm [ __ ] down for halo wars
well you got a beast pc now halo wars 3
is it on pc hello
is on pc yeah and it runs really well
i've got i've gotten so many games that
i just i'm
i know i'm gonna go home today and be
like okay i'm downloading all these
games now
time to replay all these twenty seven
here's what we should do we should all
do like a a
a day where we all just say like let's
all play each other's like choice of
game yeah
sure we should do that that should be
fun we'll do it we'll do it
we'll stream at all be a whole day thing
yeah
all right uh should we move on to joey's
stupidity yeah yeah sure all right
prepare for one of the normiest
[ __ ] three dude i mean you've already
had my three by three
okay
okay okay okay um
uh let me ask shocked by any of them
so you're like a death below like
completely normie then yeah you haven't
gone for final fantasy seven well no i
think six is like the
the second normiest choice yeah dude
i didn't know terraria was like up in
your top nine okay terraria i've
dead ass like if you go onto my steam
i've deadass play terraria for about 500
hours
i was so into toro when i first came out
we don't need to talk about persona
though right
yeah okay obviously
i don't really need to talk about breath
of the wild obviously um
why should marry wood out of all of the
marios okay super mario world for me
okay because
a lot of these games like especially the
older ones like um
kirby's nightmare and dreamland and
final fantasy 6 and stuff like that yeah
i got them as
hand-me-downs from my cousin so like
basically all the super nintendo games
and like especially like kirby games
especially
um yeah all hand-me-downs and super
mario world was one of the first
like mario games i had like properly sat
down yeah
knowing it was a mario game yeah like
you know there's like games when you're
like
really really young where it's just like
this is just a video game
but i don't know like what this is it's
just a fun thing that's on my screen
yeah yeah yeah but super mario world was
the one where i was like okay
i'm playing this knowing fully well that
this is a mario game and that i love
mario games and you can't you can't hate
on that that's literally like
one of the best games of all time it is
one of the best [ __ ] platforms
like it was a tie between super mario
world for me because we can only choose
one game per franchise right yeah
obviously
for a mario game hard as [ __ ] for me to
choose but it was a tie between super
mario world and yoshi's island oh
yoshi's island i [ __ ] love you i was
like both of them are like
equal number one for me right um but i
ign top games of all yeah
there's one honestly except for clan ad
that's that that's that's yeah
yeah that's like joey's like
individualized yeah
for me was just like okay that's what
like really sold me like anime games
out of everything on here that like well
i
that will make it known that it's a joey
list it's clannad yeah
if you if you remove that like i
literally have no idea
have you removed clan ed it's like oh i
see you were also born in the 90s this
is the first thing you've typed in
top wii game top ps5 game top
top game boy game top nsnes game and
then you've been like i'll have those
i'll have those yeah okay wait wait
which which super mario is it where
there's like there's a level where
there's a sun
trying to kill you that's super mario
brothers three i had nightmares of that
really that song i couldn't beat it and
i kept i kept having nightmares yeah
dude that game's [ __ ] hot like that
level is [ __ ] hard yeah
have you guys ever played the original
mario yeah yeah yeah i think i think
i've actually played
every mainline mario game because
[ __ ] nintendo re-releases it every
[ __ ] year and says
pay me 10 bucks for the same [ __ ]
game and i'm like okay did you play as a
kid
yeah okay as a kid did you want to eat
the [ __ ] chocolate the bricks
was that just me no
[Laughter]
but like yeah as a kid i remember i i
have a distinct memory of just
looking at the bricks and just thinking
man those look delicious
they kind of look like chocolate that is
definitely like i hope you didn't say
that out loud because your parents were
like oh god
oh [ __ ] we should we should take this
game away
oh god all right that's just me okay in
my life
much like gaunt right i i think my three
by three is a little bit of a lie
because there's a bunch of games on here
because to me i was like okay
for me through and through i was always
a nintendo simp
yeah nintendo seemed from the moment i
got my first game console to today
yeah but because of that i feel i've
kind of put
too many nintendo games on my 3x3 i mean
i mean like it's
it's it's it's the first thing that came
to your mind right yeah but i would okay
there's one game that i would [ __ ]
put on here on the xbox
and uh that's uh this game called ssx
tricky
of course oh my god i forgot about that
i put so many hours into that game that
was such a good
that was such a good [ __ ] game oh my
god dude
ssx tree okay for those who don't know
ssx is the snowboarding game
right and it did you play snowboard kids
as well on the n64 was that just me oh i
played a little bit of that
yeah i played a little bit of that i
think i think it was the first time i
saw ssx3 because i think my
dad got it yeah because like my dad was
the one who bought the xbox because he
wanted to play like a bunch of like
racing car games and one of the racing
card games that me and my dad [ __ ]
bonded over was burn
out three that's the [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] amazing which i would also put
on my three by three but like
he also brought home this game called
ssx tricky i'm like i never [ __ ]
cared about snowboarding i didn't know
what the [ __ ] this is
joey we haven't seen snow we live in
australia yeah that's going to do
something legit the first time i ever
saw snow it was an sssg
but like i played it and the moment you
hear that [ __ ] title screen music i
was like
hell the [ __ ] yeah like to me
i'm just getting reminded but ssx tricky
is on like the same level as tony hawk
yeah in my mind in terms of just
addictive gameplay
tony hawk's pro skater 2. yeah i never
played any of these games oh
sorry like ssx trick i don't know i
think the one thing i
[ __ ] optimized the [ __ ] out of ssx
yeah yeah because it was probably the
one game where i was like
no no no this isn't the perfect score i
know i can fit
one more trick into this show when
you're addicted to a game it's like yeah
i know i could fit like one more 180
into this like
trick combo of this one yeah and i would
just keep
[ __ ] playing this over and over and
over and over again i think i 100
percent of it actually it was probably
one of the first games a hundred percent
i think i was close to 100 percent
as well i mean all of these games have
100 percent yeah yeah um in terms of
like
uh pokemon silver the original silver
it's the one game where i've actually
broken the in-game timer like i played
so much of silver right now
yeah like how do you do that what is the
in-game timer the in-game time the max
in-game time is 999
hours and that's reasonable which is
reasonable it's like a thousand hours
right but the only way i achieve that is
because of
like you know obviously you play through
the game and then you're like okay
well i've finished i've gotten all 16
badges what do i do now yeah
complete the decks okay i'll do that
what's the step after that
get every pokemon to level 100. okay
i've done that
right get all the shinies and i did that
with you what the
[ __ ] i did that would you take that to
yourself i did that to myself because
at the time right i was borrowing my
friend's game boy color
right like we kind of like this was
during the time where like i had like a
couple of childhood friends like
lived nearby where we met each other
often enough where it's like
can i borrow your n64 can i borrow your
super nintendo or whatever
yeah so i never actually owned the game
boy color
and but i had pokemon silver
um i don't remember where i got it from
maybe i borrowed it from my friend
probably like that probably something
like that but like i borrowed the game
boy color enough times where
i was like and it was the only gameboy
yeah and also silver was the only
gameboy color game i had
right as well so it's like whenever i
saw the gameboy color just sitting on my
desk i'm like
well i mean i could just [ __ ] play
this yeah and kill some time
and as a kid you know you have no
concept of time as you're playing a game
right so it's like
so yeah i just [ __ ] was like well
literally got nothing else to do other
than i guess i'll just try and catch all
the shinies
oh my god and i [ __ ] did that and
that sounds like torture and i maxed out
the in-game clock i was like oh
999 is the max all right i got it now
jesus yeah nice joey
i'm telling you like you think you're
like you know god thinks he's like you
know
once you're into a game you get addicted
to it yeah i get [ __ ] no no no no no
no i i know you do you're on another
level and like kirby's uh
nightmare in dreamland was the first
ever game i owned because the gameboy
advance was the first console i own i
think i've played that game
i've never played a single kirby game
okay this game
was the game that got me to kirby right
since then i [ __ ] love every kirby
game and like
i'm telling you like if you're ever
feeling sad
just play a kirby yeah it might be the
most like your child
yeah so i'm gonna describe you a copy of
cubby's dream literally if
like you might think it's like childish
and dumb and like [ __ ] easy or
whatever
yeah but it is literally impossible to
play a kirby game
and not be happy like it's it's just
it's this challenge except there is
there is there's something
there's something about it where it's
like i might be in the shittiest [ __ ]
mood
and i'll play like 30 minutes of any
kirby game yeah immediately happy
right and like i think that's why i
liked playing it because i was like i
don't want to play a game that makes me
sad i mean
later on in my adulthood i was like yes
jerry's like heavy rain
heavy rain yes metal gear solid give me
all of that sure
yes uh i i would like a bit of
depression please and uh
and i think again like that's another
reason why i like played a lot of like
animal crossing for example or like
you know again like pokemon it's like
you can't you put animal crossing in
like
the top nine in your life yeah damn yeah
okay because
every like this one in particular well
well yeah honestly
well wild world specifically because i
was [ __ ] obsessed with the ds
and this was one of the few this is the
ds one i was gonna say cause i heard a
lot of like
you know now that now that people have
like calmed down about an animal
crossing the first one i've heard a lot
of people being like you know
it is good but it does feel like it's
lacking in a lot of ways yeah and that
they're adding in the functions that
were in the previous ones
yeah yeah literally all the add-ons that
they currently added
what is the point of animal crossing
yeah i mean i i i feel like
i'm trying to understand why there's
like anti-vaxxers when i'm watching
like i like i hear i hear what you're
saying i get it but
i'm seeing it and i'm like i don't get
it at all i i totally get
people which is why i was really shocked
at
how popular the newest one got yeah
because to me
animal crossing a lot like harvest moon
yeah i always thought was like that
one niche series where it's like if you
weren't into it from the beginning
doesn't matter how many new games they
bring out you'll never get into it i
mean like the more people talk about it
the more i'm just like well this is just
a pay your mortgage simulator yeah so
i i watch it and i'm like okay so you go
hit that rock and then you you get some
stone okay and then you go and talk to a
guy who gives you a
recipe for something that you didn't
want and then you go and make that thing
and it's like a cabinet that you might
not need
and then i'm like confusing if you don't
want it you can sell that and then
everything is just seems
so slow and of course it's nintendo so
[ __ ] is just unnecessarily complicated
like i saw someone going to like uh
someone else's island
and it took like a minute of like
cutscenes to go to someone's island or
something yeah and then like everything
just seemed slow
in it and i was like why i think that's
the entire point of animal crossing it's
supposed to be slow
because it's not supposed to be like
[Music]
uh [ __ ] uh harvest moon
i get the sims though right because
you're kind of like you're kind of
trying to
you you're kind of like living a life
like that maybe that maybe you couldn't
like live
in real life you know what's really
weird i never got into the sims
i know i never got into the sims i
always thought sims was really boring
yeah which is weird because of an animal
crossing because the thing is i really
like simulation games
but i've never like never a life
simulator game i've always liked what it
is
you know why i never go into the sims
because it wasn't cute
honestly i understand that honestly you
look at harvest moon you look at animal
crossing you're like that's [ __ ]
adorable i
i was i was never into sims but like
when i started voice acting and it's a
weird tangent yeah like i started seeing
sims voice acting project everywhere
right people making their own movies in
sims
this was a huge thing oh yeah like
machinima yeah and i was just like
what the [ __ ] this is ugly and it looks
dumb yeah and it's like the animations
of sims like
yeah and then they would you have to
like voice act to it and i'm
i feel like that's part of the like old
age of the internet there's something
there's some campiness to it that i feel
like has its own charm
yeah right absolutely it would be like
it's like this oscar-worthy drama
performed via sims animation it's like
what the [ __ ]
but i think that's the whole appeal
right because when uh animal crossing
first came out
right i think i read this somewhere and
correct me if i'm wrong internet but
i think the whole appeal of animal
crossing was it was supposed to be
marketed towards
housewives in japan right who wanted
something to do
as you know their husbands or
significant others were out working all
day yeah that's literally how they
marketed it because i was like it was a
non-challenging game
no literally it was like it was a game
where i was like are you tired of being
in the kitchen all day
yeah literally it's like because it's
it's so not challenging
and also it's non-stressful either it's
like it's a game that like
literally just gets all your stress off
because you forget about everything in
the
in your real world yeah where you can
just focus on a completely
separate just there are no you know
stresses or no
i guess like bad things to happen with
like any consequence whatsoever in this
world
right so it's literally nintendo was
like imma create a distraction for
stressed adults
and call it animal crossing because i
remember my first and only experience
with animal crossing was the original
animal crossing on the gamecube
right and the only reason i knew about
it right
was because i don't i think for the
longest time it just wasn't available in
the uk like yeah
it was only available like they
translated it but it was only available
in the us
yeah and i had heard about it from like
this nintendo gaming pc i don't know
gaming magazine yeah gaming magazine
gaming magazine that's what i meant to
say this nintendo gaming magazine
and they were like it just got like
super good reviews and i'm just like
holy [ __ ] this must be a banger of the
game every [ __ ] review is given
every review is giving this five out of
five yeah i'm just like holy [ __ ] this
this
this this is a must-get game why is this
not available in the uk right so i
literally had to like
look up some like import websites and
like
like seriously like i had to import
animal crossing from the us
buy like a specialized import disk where
like because
um yeah because um old gamecube games
were region logged so you couldn't just
put a us disk into a uk device
you needed a special disk that you
needed to insert into the gamecube um to
regen unlock it so that you can put
animal crossing into yeah yeah and
so i had to research and do that to do
that by myself with a
very limited budget because i i didn't
really have much of a budget to work
with back then
um but i i had saved up and i brought
animal crossing
and i was just like this is gonna be
amazing guys this is gonna be an amazing
game
i've imported this game which is [ __ ]
expensive to import a game and i bought
like
extra hardware on top of that just so i
could play the game because every review
said it was amazing
yeah and then i started playing it i'm
just like when's the gameplay kicking
i was like okay it's an awfully long
cutscene yeah yeah i was like okay
okay i was picking apples i'm just like
so i'm
the gameplay is going to kick in
sometime i'm going to have a point to
why i'm doing this
because i i expected it to be on the
same level as like pokemon
or stuff like that when i'm catching
stuff or i'm like i'm going on an
adventure yeah and i'm just like
okay surely when i pay off this mortgage
that's when the gameplay all kicking
so i play i play animal crossing and
like and i
i and i [ __ ] paid tom nook back or
whatever the [ __ ] is i pay off
i pay off my mortgage because i'm just
like there must be a reason why every
game
every magazine is giving this five stars
pay off my mortgage
and then the game just continues and
then tom looks like
here's another mortgage
what's interesting is like okay because
you like games like
banjo-kazooie or like jrpgs where
there's like a whole like
collect like a collecting element to it
right yeah like linear games more than
open world and stuff like that i i do
like linear games more than openly right
i like it's funny because i feel like
i do like the idea of open world games
but if i'm going to sit down and play
something then i much prefer linear
games right because one of my favorite
aspects of animal crossing personally is
like the whole like
catching fish and bugs and collecting
all the artworks and collecting all the
furniture
like it's basically the collecting
portion of it right whereas a lot of
other people who play the game you know
enjoy the whole like you know
diy you know creating your own amazing
looking town amazing looking house kind
of thing to me that's like
second yeah number one for me is
definitely like i need to complete my
fish index i need to complete my bug
index
why why why do you want to do that
because i got that love
from playing all the jrpgs right and
like and
obviously six is up there because like
there was that for six
for me as well but like i think the
reason why i picked six and i think
why final fantasy 6 is my favorite not
only final fantasy game but my favorite
jrpg ever
yeah is because like it was the first
game where i was like this is a work of
art
right like this is like not just a game
it's like the gameplay is like
cool you know i've played all the
previous final fantasies like four and
one and [ __ ] like that
right the gameplay is basically the same
but six was the first time where i was
like
i didn't know story could be this good i
didn't know game music could be this
good
i didn't know you could have this much
immersion in a game
yeah where and i got to like the fight
like the fact that you know people still
talk
to this day about like the final fight
scene right yeah i like the six
like final fantasy 6 i feel like it's
overshadowed by final fantasy vii but
everyone i know who's played final
fantasy 6 holds it higher than final
fantasy xv i've always said the true
final fantasy that's like
six is the true final fantasy fans pick
yeah yeah right because it's like
you're not persuaded by like the
graphics quote unquote because this was
the last
2d final fantasy iron seven is roblox
yeah seven is roblox but people still
put it on this [ __ ] like pedestal of
graphics right it's like
what are you seeing and like you know
don't get me wrong seven is also a good
game yeah
i also like seven but six was i don't
know there's something about it where i
was like
this game could look like absolute [ __ ]
right and
the story and the music and everything
just the immersion of getting into this
world
is so [ __ ] well done yeah where it's
like
i don't care how this game looks um yeah
it was like
to this day like the [ __ ] battle
thing the decisive battle theme from
final fantasy 6
gives me a [ __ ] heart on every time i
listen to it it's like persona 5 and
final fantasy 6
to easily have the best [ __ ] battle
theme music of
any game i mean i can't comment really i
haven't played any final fantasy so i
feel bad i can't
judge you there's a lot of there's a lot
of final
talked about hating turn-based battles
yeah i am regretting
uh not putting i wish i put runescape on
my list now
oh yeah i'm surprised runescape wasn't
on your list i played runescape that was
like the first game i ever like had a
membership
for actually maybe club penguin yeah
club penguin was the first one for me
penguin on my list dude going on those
[ __ ] tubes down there the snow slope
tipping the ice becoming the cia agent
like definitely like when you say
emotion in the world man i was so into
those [ __ ] quests and [ __ ] oh yeah
going to like monkey island and stuff oh
my god
so good just put runescape on my list
yeah i want to want to remake my three
by three after talking to you guys about
it i could honestly make a three by
three of like
each console like did you would you want
to talk about tawario at all
terraria okay terraria for me was like
so
when it came out i had already like
known about minecraft
because minecraft obviously came out
before terraria why is minecraft not on
here in terrarius
i thought you liked minecraft more than
terraria i think minecraft for me is
kind of like
i like it and it's a game that i can
always come back to
but i don't think i was like as heavily
into it as i was with terraria because
right
i think terraria came out when i was in
maybe like middle school or high school
or something
okay and the only ever time where i
would spend
like i would not sleep right and be in
like a [ __ ] skype call with my
friends in high school
was playing terraria right like there
were so many nights where
after school you know we'd be on the bus
home we'd be like all right
we're playing terraria after dinner yeah
like 7 8 pm
yeah yeah all right cool we all get on a
skype call and we [ __ ] play tomorrow
till like 6 a.m like all right see you
in school in two hours
like i had so many nights like that
playing terraria right i don't know why
i could have easily done that with
minecraft to be honest but i think it's
because
i don't know there's something about
like side-scrolling games that just
just just tickle my fancy it looks fun
every time i see terraria i'm like yeah
that looks like fun
yeah i mean was there a point to
terraria
it's kind of like is there a point in
minecraft yeah it's like it's kind of
like the point of my i mean there is
actually like a story where it's like
you have to go through and like there's
like a bunch of
story dungeons kind of thing right you
have to discover right yeah
there is an end game there's a bunch of
content for free right oh yeah
everyone's always like the chad terraria
dlc for free yeah
exactly i think i have terraria i think
i paid for it i just never played it i
don't know why
it's really really fun and it's it's
it's like minecraft for me as well where
it's like
if i just need like a game to just kind
of mindlessly play and just relax too
then i'll either put minecraft tutorials
yeah
yeah it's just a other than that other
than that it is the most vanilla 3x3
i've ever made i mean like i mean i
totally understand why it's your 3x3
uh it's this is very much a joey 3x3
these are like nine games that i can
always come back to
and it's probably the most amount of
time i've ever spent on any game i've
wrote down a bunch of other games that i
wish i could have put on
yeah i think i did too borderlands 2 i
thought was really [ __ ] good
league of legends oh i pulled it i put
gary's mod on here
maybe portal 2 mario party 2.
yeah i'm surprised nobody put mario
party here because i wanted to talk
about mario about the party
party too with that story mission
challenge oh hands down the best my
reply
the amount of blisters i've gotten from
mario party man
yeah my god whoever designs
the like arc yeah whoever designed the
n64 controller
like he just hated humanity he woke up
and he chose violence yeah
he would like put it into games where
i'm like i'm sure there's better
solutions
that was like a rowing down the uh uh
rowing down a like a raft thing yeah
yeah yeah
the man just the man just saw an
ergonomics book and just set it on fire
yeah
like yeah because yeah like i said with
the rowing one
the the mechanic was you to like go this
way if you wanted the boat to go this
way or go the other way if you wanted to
go that way yeah i'm pretty sure that's
if i might be wrong
i think so and uh i'm like you could
have just done literally anything else
like why did
you know there's like eleanor yeah
my favorite mario party 2 mini game was
i think it was on mario party 2.
it was one where you have to like there
was like it was like swamps domino i
love that one oh that was a good one
yeah
[ __ ] no you have to like mash like
knock down as many likes
yeah yeah yeah i love the one the
skateboarding one as well oh yeah
uh the blow up the balloon and like as
full as you think it can go
oh that was a good one that was a good
one that was a good one yeah i just love
the fact that [ __ ] the go-karting one
go-karting one [ __ ] sucks
what i love about too is just that it
doesn't [ __ ] around it does not hold
your hand
it's like if you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
yeah yeah so good
um pokemon coliseum oh oh stadium for me
on gamecube
the one with the story yeah and we could
catch other people's pokemon the
darkness i realized like i got
super into pokemon snap pokemon snap was
there's a new one coming in
i know i know i know oh it's out today
oh is that
yeah we're recording on the 30th of
march oh wow wait wait to spoil it let's
go
um uh professor layton i actually really
liked those games
i played the first one it was really
really good yeah and then i had an
honorable mention for the worst [ __ ]
game i've ever bought in my life
uh and i completely regretted it we
music probably
you ever seen this game no [ __ ]
garbage game
you had to buy it with a controller as
well so it was like 90 bucks when you
were a kid
so i asked my parents for it because i
was like wow look at shigeru miyamoto on
stage [ __ ] wagon
you get this game and literally to play
the instruments you just like waggle a
controller and it sounds like [ __ ]
and like that's the whole game there's a
whole i'm gonna show you it later you're
gonna be like oh is that the one where
you have to like conduct
you can conduct and it doesn't work very
well at all and then there's one where
you like can play a trumpet and all you
do is press the button and hold the wii
this i think i've seen and then there's
one where you play guitar and you just
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] it was garbage i've seen
like i've seen meme videos of it
[ __ ] oh yeah for me horizon zero dawn i
mean i i feel like self-explanatory
anything with a good story and good
characters fire emblem three houses
yeah i put fire emblem awakening oh yeah
that was really
the gameplay more than the story and
fire emblem yeah i i mean i the reason i
put three houses on
is because i'm ah about the gameplay
because it's turn based but
it was just fire emblem with persona and
i'm just like yeah literally
this is this is everything i need yeah
like this gives me a reason to get
through
get uh play through the game uh metroid
pla metroid prime
oh cool uh [ __ ] incredible uh and
that was one of the few games where i
was totally invested in the world um
and it went again what i when i went
again
went against what i said before because
you had to kind of figure it out
yourself
yeah um but the
walking gameplay season one i mean
that's uh oh this is the
telltale game yeah wow um that was i
mean bro
it was good and then it became bra i
mean it wasn't really a game it was just
a good story yeah
for me uh uh okami is up there yeah okay
really [ __ ] good uh obviously i said
rhythm heaven
link to the past yeah wii sports yeah
yeah yeah uh smash bros melee obviously
yeah obviously um
and then like recently like i recently
just played like the two bayonetta games
yeah those were really [ __ ] good to
honestly this there's too many like why
why why do we have to just confine it to
nine because you know you gotta have
something to talk about
like a five
what i've realized after uh doing this
episode is that
um there are so many games that i love
that i just did not remember
yeah um because i i i go back to my
comfort picks but man and there's a
there's a lot of games there what's the
one game that we're all gonna like if we
had to pick one game after today that we
have to
then we're gonna go back and play red
alert two
ssx is tricky for me honestly you didn't
mention the soundtrack of ssx tricky
because because
the amount of time like trick
is right that's what made that game so
good to play man
like because i realized the reason i
freaked out was because for the longest
time i couldn't remember
why i wanted to learn snowboarding so
bad
i had just thought that snow
snowboarding seems cool
you didn't listen to the theme as you
were learning to snowboard i did not
and uh like you stopped like you had
just reminded me yeah
ssx tricky is the sole reason why i
wanted to snowboard
so bad and that's why yeah it's like
tony hawk's pro skater 2 was the reason
why i wanted to learn how to do this
yeah yeah i
i i just blanked out that memory of my
life
my [ __ ] god
boys for halo wars with me yeah yeah um
i mean like i think i think we've gotten
a good taste of what our taste in video
games are
i wonder who you more like viewers are
you more of a gun connor or
joey i wonder let us know down in the
comments who is the best taste and why
is it me why is it sonic riders why are
those sonic riders battalion wars 2 why
is it the best
sonic riders [ __ ] you i'll fight anyone
i like how this has probably been the
most civil episode regarding our taste
it's like
i think it's because me and joey aren't
true gamers so we're just like
true we're too casual we're too casual
but hey
let's give a special thank you to our
patrons look at them
they're all beautiful people wonderful
gamers
gamers pro gamers so many of them had to
throw in one nakey jakey references
just had to do it of course i did but
hey if you'd like to support the show
then make sure to go over to our patreon
patreon.comtrashtest
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our faces listen to us on spotify
yeah um there's nothing else to say go
game yeah
go game goodbye gamers i hope you're
listening to this while playing every
game we mentioned for optimum gaming
experience
honestly you've just stopped the
cartridge when we mentioned the game yep
exactly
all right well i guess uh yeah that's it
there's something else to say see you
later gamers
gamers no wait rise up gamers
rest gamers
[Music]
you